-- MR CHIU.
YOU'RE OUR FIRST AUTHOR.
VERY MUCH WILL GET STARTED ON
YEAH WILL -- YES AND WILL START
IS IT WE HAVE AGREED TO START IS
SUBCOMMITTEE -- WAIT SANTIAGO AS
WELL SANTIAGO I'M AFRAID SIGNED
UP.
FOR THE ARMY.
IT'S OKAY ALL RIGHT WE'LL START
WITH MR CHEER.
AND I'M THRILLED.
ALL RIGHT SO MR CHU HAS ITEM
NUMBER.
TWO AB FIVE OH EIGHT DRINKING
WATER CONSOLIDATION AND
EXTENSION OF SERVICE DOMESTIC
WELLS [inaudible]
SELECT COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I EFFORTS WILL LIKE TO
STEP TO COMMITMENT COMP
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR WORKING
WITH -- A MY MY OFFICE ON THIS.
AB FIVE ZERO EIGHT BILLS ON
CALIFORNIA'S ONGOING EFFORT TO
PROVIDE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER.
BALL ALL CALIFORNIANS
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL.
IMPROVED ON EXISTING WATER BORE
PROCESSES CREATED UNDER AB
TWENTY FIVE ALL ONE TO DELIVERY.
TO DELIVERING SAFE WATER TO
SMALL COMMITTEE THE BUT ALL
CALLS TO THE WATER DISTRICT.
AND SO THIS BILL.
A OF THIS
THIS BILL -- A. B. FIVE OH EIGHT
REQUIRES TO DADE DURING THE
PUBLIC OUTREACH AND CONSIDERING
ALTERED CONSIDERATION.
CONSOLIDATIONS OR EXTENSION OF
THE SERVICES.
THE WATER BOARD INFORMED TO
RESIDENTS IF THE OWNER OF THE
DON'T DAHLE MASTIC WILL OR TWO
WELDING IS WITHHOLDING CONSENT
TO THE STATE FUNDED
CONSOLIDATION OR EXPANSION OF
SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL PROHIBIT
REACHED THE RECEIVING WATER
SYSTEM FROM CHARGER IN THE STATE.
THE FEED MEANT FOR NEW
DEVELOPMENT WHEN A PROJECT ARMED
MEN TO PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING
WATER TO EXISTING COMMUNITY.
THE FEES CHARGED FOR THE NEW
DEVELOPMENT MAKES SENSE HOWEVER
DEALS CONSOLIDATION EFFORT
ALWAYS TO EXISTING COMEY
CONSUMMATED HE'S AND HE'S FEES
TAKE AWAY THE STATE RESOURCES.
THAT WILL GO DIRECTLY INTO
PROVIDING CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
IF WE ALLOW RECEIVING WATERS
SYSTEMS TO CHARGE A FEE WERE NOT
APPROPRIATE.
WE RUN THE RISK OF THE PROJECT
GREEN TOO COSTLY FOR THE STATE
TO PURSUE.
A HALTING POTENTIAL PROJECTS AND
LEAVING RESIDENTS WITH ALL ****
TO STATE SAFE DRINKING WATER.
THIS BILL IS WORKING TO REDUCE
EXISTING ADMINISTRATIVE AREAS
RETURN TO SMALL DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
AB FIVE ZERO A IS SPONSORED BY
THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE.
A POLICY LINK CLEAN WATER ACTION
COMEDY WATER CENTER AND OTHERS
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE -- MICHAEL
CLAIBORNE FROM THE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO GIVE SOME MORE
BACKGROUND IN SUPPORTING OFF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MY
NAME IS MIKE CLAIBORNE I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP FOR
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHICH IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE NONPROFIT BASED
IN FRESNO WITH -- AN OFFICE IN
EAST COACHELLA AS WELL -- I'M
HERE TODAY BECAUSE THERE'S A
DRINKING WATER CRISIS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MORE THAN ONE MILLION PEOPLE IN
THIS STATE LACKS ACCESS TO SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
AND A BIG PORTION OF THE PROBLEM
IS ATTRIBUTED TO HOUSEHOLDS
RELIANT ON DOMESTIC WELLS WHICH
SERVE NEARLY TWO MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE STATE -- AND ARE
TYPICALLY IS SHALLOWER THAN
MUNICIPAL WELLS SO ARE MORE
VULNERABLE TO WATER QUALITY
IMPACTS AS WELL AS DROUGHT
IMPACTS.
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE IN RECENT
YEARS SPURRED ON BY THE TRANSFER
OF THE DRINKING WATER PROGRAM TO
THE STATE WATER BOARD IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AS WELL AS THE
PASSAGE OF SB EIGHTY EIGHT AND
IT AB TWENTY FIVE A ONE IN
RECENT YEARS WHICH EXPANDED THE
AUTHORITY OF THE WATER BOARD TO
ORDER EXTENSIONS.
OF SAFE DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS
TO COMMUNITIES THAT LACK SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
SINCE PASSAGE OF TWENTY FIVE A
ONE WE HAVE IDENTIFIED SEVERAL.
WAYS IN WHICH THE PROCESS FOR
MANDATING EXTENSION OF SERVICE
CAN BE IMPROVED.
AN EXAMPLE FOR THE NEED OF
FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS IS PROVIDED
BY A COMMUNITY CALLED TOMBSTONE
TERRITORY -- WHICH IS IN FRESNO
COUNTY AND LESS THAN A MILE FROM
THE CITY LATER AND LIMITS OF THE
CITY OF SANGER -- THE COMMUNITY
PRESENTLY LACKS ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER -- THEY HAVE
NITRATES IN THEIR PRIVATE WELLS
THEY ALSO OF TCP.
AND BACTERIA.
BECAUSE OF THIS CONTAMINATION
RESIDENTS HAVE IDENTIFIED --
EXTENSION OF SERVICE FROM THE
CITY OF SAYING -- AS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER THE WAY THE WITH THE
RELEVANT STATUTE READS PRESENTLY --
THE STATE MUST.
AS A FIRST STEP IN THE PROCESS
OBTAIN WRITTEN CONSENT FROM THE
OWNERS OF DOMESTIC WELLS AND THE
UNIT SERVED BY DOMESTIC WELLS.
AB FIVE OH EIGHT WOULD MOVE THAT
REQUIREMENT DOWN TO LATER IN THE
PROCESS TO BE PERFORMED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE FEASIBILITY
STUDY.
AND THE IDEA THERE IS TO NOT CUT
OFF -- PROJECT AND PRIVATE
RELEVANT INFORMATION TO DOMESTIC
WELL OWNERS EARLY ON IN THE
PROCESS IN ORDER TO BUILD
SUPPORT -- SIMILARLY THE BILL
WOULD.
ALSO REQUIRE THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO PROVIDE WRITTEN NOTICE
TO HOUSEHOLDS SERVED BY DOMESTIC
WELLS BOTH OWNERS AND THE
CURRENT OCCUPANTS OF THE WATER
QUALITY PROBLEM.
IMPACTS THE HEALTH AND POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS INCLUDING EXTENSION OF
SERVICE FROM A NEARBY WATER
SYSTEM.
FINALLY WHEN CONSOLIDATION OR
EXTENSION OF DRINKING WATER
SERVICE IS MANDATED THE BILL
WOULD CLARIFY THAT CAPACITY FEES
MET SERVE NEW DEVELOPMENT.
ARE NOT CHARGED TO THE STATE.
IN HOLD THE BILL WOULD MAKE THE
PROCESS FOR EXTENSION OF
DRINKING WATER SERVICE BOTH MORE
TRANSPARENT AND MORE EFFICIENT.
AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
HEATING REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR
SAY HER PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION LEAGUE AND
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER.
FOREIGN COMMON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OUR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT I WANNA.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
CHIU.
I'LL WAIT WE HAD A QUESTION.
YEAH WITH THOSE.
OKAY OKAY.
YEAH WE I WE COULD REALLY USE A
MEMBERS SO WE COULD MAKE A
MOTION.
I I WOULD SECOND IT -- BUT ALL
RIGHT BUT WE NEED TO MORE
MEMBERS HERE TO HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE CAN DO THAT THANK YOU BUT IT
IS AN EXCELLENT BELL AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU.
FOR TAKING OUR AMENDMENTS WHICH
ARE MEANT TO ALLOW -- WELL YOUR
BILL WELL HOPEFULLY SIMPLIFY
PROCEDURES BUT WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO ALLOW THE BOARD TO MAKE THE
FINAL.
DECISION AS TO WHEN TO MAKE THE
WHEN YOU DO THE AFFILIATION AND
AND MAKE.
THEIR MOTIONS FORWARDED TO TREAT
THE WELL BUT HOPEFULLY THIS WILL
ALLOW FOR SIMPLER PROCESS AND
THEREFORE.
WE'RE I'M VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK -- FOR BOOK ALL
RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT MISTER SANTIAGO.
HE'S GONNA BE SUPER QUICK OKAY
WELL GO WITH THE SUPER QUICK.
ONE MR GRAY.
THIS IS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING THIS THIS IS A VERY
BUSY TIME WE HAVE PEOPLE
PRESENTING BILLS AT THE SAME
TIME THEY'RE ON COMMITTEES.
SO IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET A
QUORUM AND IT'S DIFFICULT FOR
EVERYONE TO BE HERE.
SAU ALL RIGHT MISTER GRAY.
THEY MISTER APPRECIATE YOUR
HOSPITALITY AND ALLOWING ME --
TO MOVE QUICK WITH THIS BILL.
MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL.
TO STRENGTHEN SEE QUIRK --
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL LAW IT
RELATES TO THE BAY DELTA PLAN
UPDATE AND THE WATER RESOURCE
CONTROL BOARD AND I WOULD TAKE
THE CHAIR AND IS.
COMMITTEE STAFFER -- THEIR
EXCEPTIONAL HELP IN COMING TO I
THINK A STRONG BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR --
YES AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S
IT'S A BILL THAT WILL ALLOW FOR
MORE TRANSPARENCY IN THAT.
AND ALSO FOR THE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE MORE INPUT.
SO I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS HERE AND THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING OUR AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU SIR ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NOW MISTER SANTIAGO
WHO IS VERY GENEROUS WITH HIS
TIME -- I'M SORRY SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION I'M SORRY I FORGOT
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
YEAH WELL.
I'M GOING A LITTLE [inaudible]
TOO IT.
SO OFTEN.
TELL DEL HAND WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT
THE BILL GOOD.
ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY.
MR SANTIAGO NOW.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY -- TO PRESENT.
ON A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAS HELPED US ON
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS I WANT TO
FIRST.
START BY SAYING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THAT YOUR SUPPORT ON
ON THE ISSUE OF EXCITED IN OUR
COMMUNITY -- OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS ALSO I THINK YOU
CAN BE STAFF BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN INCREDIBLY -- INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL IN HELPING US CRAFTED
LEGISLATION AND HELP US WALK
THROUGH THESE -- THROUGH THIS
ISSUE OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS WELL.
BUT I I'M NOT GOING TO HAVE TO
REPEAT -- EVERY SINGLE DETAIL
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD BUT WITH.
THE WORST POLLUTION THAT IS THAT
HAS BEEN FOUND ON THE WESTERN
COAST OF THE UNITED STATES BUT
EXCITED REALLY DID CONTAMINATE
OVER TEN THOUSAND HOMES THAT WE
KNOW -- PARTICULARLY AFFECTING
REGIONS OF THE AREA THAT I
REPRESENT LIKE BULL HEIGHTS --
SEE HUNTING PARK IN ALSO OTHER
AREAS OF MY COLLEAGUES REPRESENT.
AND IS THE LEGISLATURE BEEN
GENEROUS.
TO HELP US WILL WITH DOLLARS
CLOSED UP AT THE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDING WHEN WE CARRIED AB ONE
EIGHTEEN TODAY WERE ASKING --
FOR THIS FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO
HELP US MOVE FORWARD AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY TWO WHICH WOULD A WHICH
WOULD ALLOW US TO LOAN ONCE MORE.
A MONIES TO HELP US REMEDIATE --
THE AFFECTED AREAS AND IT WOULD
CALL 410-0 MILLION DOLLARS MORE
I TO CONTINUES CONVERSATION IN
CLEAN IT UP WE HAVE HIGH LEVELS
OF CANCER -- WE'VE AT EXTREMELY
HIGH LEVELS OF LEAD POLLUTION --
AND WE THINK THAT THIS IS A STEP
FOR DTS HE WILL SAY THAT IT'LL
BE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION
IN TOTAL TO CLEAN UP THIS AREA
AND THIS WILL HELP US TO GET TO
THAT POINT -- CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS AND AND WE GET
IN THANK THE COMMITTEE IN ALL
IT'S A COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ITS
HELP OVER THE OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND WE HAVE ONE
WITNESS WITH THIS WHO REALLY
STARTED -- THE MOVEMENT. TO TRY
TO SHUT DOWN EXCITED TO HELP
THAT CLEAN THE CONTAMINATION
THAT FATHER MORELLA -- FROM
RESURRECTION CHURCH THANK YOU GO
AHEAD.
HI.
YES I JUST WANT YOU CHAU
WONDERFUL ANECDOTE WITH THE
MEMBERS THAT -- OF ABOUT TWO
YEARS AGO THERE WAS A COLLECTION
OF BABY TEETH FROM THE WILL OF
FROM THE FAMILIES OF BOYLE
HEIGHTS AN EAST LA.
AND I A I KNOW WHEN I WAS A KID
I PUT THE TEETH MY TOOTH
UNDERNEATH THE PILLOW TO GET
SOME MONEY.
THE PENNY THE MEXICAN FAMILIES
THEY KEEP THE TEETH.
IN AND THEY'VE THEY'VE COLLECTED
THE STATE.
AS THEY WANTED TO STUDY BECAUSE
A DEFINITIVE STUDY TO FIND OUT
WHAT IS THE IMPACT OF LEAD.
IN THE YOUNG CHILDREN THE
INFANTS AND AND BOYLE HEIGHTS IN
THE EAST LA AREA.
AND THEY DID A SURVEY USC DID A
VERY VERY FANTASTIC STUDY.
AND THEY CAME OUT AND THEY HAD
THEY HAD TO OTHER SITES WHERE
THEY THEY TESTED AGAINST WE WERE
WE WERE COMPARED TO THE OTHER
TWO SITES.
I. BABIES TEETH SPIKE THE THE
THE THE MOUNT OF LEAD THAT WHEN
THE BABY'S TEETH SPIKED AGAINST
ALL THE OTHER COMMUNITIES.
AND IT'S JUST ONE JUST ONE
SAMPLE ONE EXAMPLE OF THE
URGENCY OF THIS AND THAT AND
WORDS OF THE H. U. M. D. --
THEIR SPOKESPERSON WHEN THEY
FOUND OUT ABOUT THIS BUT A YEARS
AGO I'VE I'VE LIVED IN WHAT TO
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AS A PASTOR I NEVER KNEW
ABOUT THIS THIS PROBLEM.
UNTIL WE WERE TOLD ABOUT THE THE
THE CANCER RISK AND IT'S IN THE
IN THE HISTORY OF THE EIGHT TO
EMPTY.
THEY THEY SAY IS THE HIGHEST
CANCER RISK IN THE HISTORY OF
THE WHOLE THE WHOLE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
SO AGAIN.
YOUR HELP IS REALLY APPRECIATED
I GO ON AND ON BUT I KNOW YOU'RE
YOU'RE LIMITED IN TIME BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUBJECT YOU FATHER
MORETTI.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS TO ESTABLISH QUORUM
QUIRK.
HERE QUIRK HERE MELENDEZ KALRA.
KALRA HERE BAUER-KAHAN HERE
BAUER-KAHAN HERE.
DALY.
CRISTINA GARCIA HOLDEN.
HOLDEN HERE MATHIS.
MATHIS HERE WOULD HAVE TO CHANGE
WE HAVE FIVE MEMBERS WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU AND HANK YOU MISTER
KALRA FOR GREEN TO SERVICE ARE --
CAST MEMBER TODAY.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT -- WE HAVE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
WE WILL -- I'M SORRY I WOULD
LIKE YEAH I WILL FINISH YOUR
BILL BEFORE I GO TO CONSENT
SORRY A SECOND.
YEAH.
ALRIGHT WE'VE MOVED TO CONTENT
CALENDAR -- WHEN NOW WE'VE MOVED
YOUR BILL?
MOVED IN SECOND [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT SO WILL TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AFTER WE
DESPITE MEDIA TAKE CARE OF YOUR
BILL [inaudible]
SORRY -- LET'S SEE ALL RIGHT AB
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THIS IS MY WHAT WITNESSES
SUPPORT THERE MAY BE ME TO USE
AS WELL OKAY -- PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
WE'VE ABBOTT ON ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHART MEMBERS
BRIAN STICK ON BEHALF.
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR PORTS CONTINUOUS
SUPPORTING GETTING ENOUGH MONEY
TO CLEAN UP THE EXCITED AREA.
ALTHOUGH WE DO NOT HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE BILL SUPERVISOR
HILDA SO LEASING OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ARE SUPPORTED BY THE
AUTHOR'S INTENTION AND FOR TO
WORK WITH MISTER SANTIAGO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR. TO
SECURE OF THE NECESSARY FUNDING
TO CLEAN UP EXCITED.
THANK YOU -- ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION -- MISTER
SALTY ANY QUESTIONS GO AHEAD --
MISS OUR CA CANNOT THANK YOU
BOTH IN CLEANING UP OUR
ENVIRONMENT IS OBVIOUSLY ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE STATE NEEDS
PROTOTYPES FOR REASONS LIKE YOU
MENTIONED THE AT THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF OUR CHILDREN -- IT'S
MY UNDERSTAND THIS WAS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET THAT
WAS FOURTEEN JANUARY I SUPPORT
THIS I'M NOT SURE WHY -- YOU
KNOW.
IT'S HAPPENING IS MANNER BUT I
DO ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT IT -- PUSHES
FORWARD MAKING SURE THAT WE GET
THE MONEY FROM THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES BECAUSE I THINK IN
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US AS A STATE TO
ENSURE THOSE.
THE POLLUTED THE ENVIRONMENT OR
PAYING FOR THE CLEANUP THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
YES -- ANYONE ELSE WITH THE
QUESTION.
ARE YOU MAY CLOSE. FOR NINETY
ONE ADDRESS THAT THAT ISSUE ON
IT.
YOU HAVE TO PUSH LEGISLATION
WITH POLICY PIECES THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
GENEROUS -- WE BELIEVE IT WE
BELIEVE IT'S MORNING WILL PUSH
IT COULD STILL THE HOUSES HAVE
TO STILL LINE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO THE
ASSEMBLY HASN'T TAKEN OBSERVE --
HASN'T APPROPRIATED IN.
UNTIL UNTIL ITS FINAL ANY THE
HAS THE SENATE SO IT'S TYPICAL I
MEAN THAT WE PUSH FOR
LEGISLATION -- THAT SOMETIME
REFLECT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T REFLECT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ON IN FACT WE
GOT NUMBER OF BILLS AND I CAN
SURE LOOK AROUND SPIKE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE WHO ALSO
HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS TO DO THE
SAME THING -- SO WILL CONTINUE
TO PUSH NONE THE LESS LAST YEAR
WE PUSH -- FOR TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS ENDED UP SETTLING WITH
SIX POINT FIVE TO THE BUDGET
PROCESS -- ANY.
WE STILL BAR STARTED BEGINNING
TO PUSH ON THE ONE BUT WE GET A
DOLLAR A MINUTE WITH A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX POINT SIX
MILLION -- TO THE WITHIN TWO AND
A HALF YEARS AGO -- SO -- BROUGH
CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR AS MUCH AS
WE POSSIBLY CAN AND ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE BEST POLICY
PIECES.
OCT THAT'S THE TOOL THAT I HAVE
AVAILABLE TO ME TO ACCESS -- THE
FUNDS.
A AND I JUST WANNA EMPHASIZE
THAT IT'S IT'S IT'S MONEY THAT
WE PLAN TO RECOUP AT SOME POINT
IN TIME -- AND I THINK IT'S AN
EASY VOTE AND IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY BOOK.
ALL RIGHT AND THE OTHER THING
ABOUT THIS IS IT'S A LOAN FROM
THE GENERAL FUND SO SHOULD WE BE
ABLE TO GET POLLUTERS TO PAY.
ARE THEY WILL REPAY THE ROUTE
THE LOAN -- AND WE'LL SEE IF
WERE ABLE TO DO THAT TELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- ALL RIGHT MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO SANTIAGO.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE MELENDEZ [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE BARRICADE HAND I
BAUER-KAHAN HI.
DALY [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
HOLDEN HOLDEN I MATHIS.
MATHIS HI WHAT A TO G. WITH A TO
G..
VERY GOOD ZERO ZAP.
THANK YOU -- CONSENT CALENDAR AS
THE MOTION IS BEEN MADE AND
SECONDED.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- TODAY
WE HAVE [inaudible]
YES.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE. FIVE ITEMS.
AB SEVEN SIX TWO QUIRK.
A. B. -- TEN NINETY THREE RUBIO --
A. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE CHAN.
AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT GLORIA IN A
BE FIFTEEN NINETY SIX COMMITTEE
ON ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND --
THAN THAT PLEASE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ADD IT CONSISTS OF AB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO QUIRK.
AB TEN NINETY THREE BLANCA RUBIO
ON AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
GLORIA AND AB FIFTEEN NINETY SIX
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS THOSE FOR BILLS ARE
GOING OR DO PASS AND WE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE
RECOMMENDATION.
OF CONSENT WE ALSO HAVE.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE CHEN
THAT'S TO PASS TO CONSENT
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
CHOLERA [inaudible]
CALLER I BAUER-KAHAN HI OUT
BAUER-KAHAN I DALY [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN I'D [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS I WHAT A TO G. WOULD HAVE
TO CHECK BY.
THAT.
SIX I DON'T THINK CALENDARS OUT.
I MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE FIVE AB.
FIVE OH EIGHT EXCELLENT IS THERE
SECOND.
I'M SURE WHO.
THE SOMEBODY SECOND OKAY MISTER
CHARICE SECOND [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
IN THE MOVIE.
THAT WILL WILL WILL DO FIVE
AWAIT FIRST AND THEN WE'LL LET
YOU MOVE.
SIX THIRTY SEVEN ALL RIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON A. B. FIVE AWAIT OKAY SO
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER -- TWO AB
FIVE OH EIGHT CHIU.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
CALLER I'D.
BAUER-KAHAN HI BAUER-KAHAN I
DALY [inaudible]
DALY NO [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN AYE [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS NO.
WHAT A TO G.?
MURATSUCHI I THIRTY FIVE TWO TWO
THAT'S OUT.
VERY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT IF YOU WOULD -- MR
MATHIS YOU CAN MOVE. SIX THREE
SEVEN SIX SEVEN A SECOND.
RIGHT MOVED AND SECONDED.
THIS IS I IT ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB SIX THIRTY SEVEN GRAY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE.
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
CALLER I'D.
BAUER-KAHAN HI BAUER-KAHAN HI
[inaudible]
DALY.
DALY I'D CRISTINA GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I WANTED TO CHECK.
WITH A TO G. HI. SEVEN SEVEN
OKAY -- NEXT WE HAVE MISTER
MULLIN.
HE HAS A V..
FIFTEEN ZERO NINE SOLID WASTE
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS.
OUR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN SENATOR HILL AND I
INTRODUCED AB FIFTEEN OH NINE IN
RESPONSE TO A FIRE CAUSED BY A
LITHIUM ION BATTERY AT THE SHORE
WAY FACILITY IN SAN MATEO COUNTY
WHICH CAUSED EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN DAMAGES.
THAT SHUT DOWN THE FACILITY FOR
NINETY DAYS AND TOOK OVER A YEAR
TO RESTORE MAKE A MOTION WITH
THE BELT.
WITH OVER A HALF MILLION LITHIUM
ION BATTERY SOLD LAST YEAR AND
THE NUMBER OF BATTERIES ON THE
MARKET EXPECTED TO DOUBLE IN THE
NEXT SEVEN YEARS THE QUANTITY OF
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES FOUND OF
THE WASTE STREAM WILL ONLY
INCREASE.
AND THE RISK OF FUTURE FIRES
ALONG WITH IT.
AB FIFTEEN OH NINE WOULD CREATE
A RECYCLING PROGRAM FOR BOTH
LOOSE LITHIUM ION BATTERIES AND
THOSE EMBEDDED IN PRODUCTS. TO
PREVENT THEM FROM BEING
IMPROPERLY DISPOSED OF IN THE
WASTE STREAM.
THIS BILL ADOPTS A PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY MODEL THAT ASKED
BATTERY AND PRODUCT MAKERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE END OF LIFE
MANAGEMENT OF THEIR PRODUCTS.
THIS MODEL ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
THESE PRODUCTS DESPITE ALL OF
THEIR PORT APPLICATIONS AND USES.
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT END OF LIFE
CONSEQUENCES WHICH THE
MANUFACTURER MUST HELP MITIGATE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE THE END
OF LIFE CONSEQUENCE FOR LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES ITS FIRES THAT ARE
PUBLICLY FINANCED THE SOLID
WASTE AND RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AS WE LEARNED IN SAN MATEO
COUNTY THE STATUS QUO PUTS THOSE
FACILITIES AND THE WORKERS TO
STAFF THEM AT REAL RISK.
PLEASE JOIN MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE PENCIL AND I TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND AVOID ANY MORE FIRES
IN OUR COUNTY OR ANYWHERE ELSE.
IN OUR STATE AND AS YOU CAN SEE
FROM THE LIST OF SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL IT'S REALLY IS A STATE
WIDE CONCERN.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN OR NINE AND NOW
ALTERNATE MY WITNESSES FOR
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AND TO
ANSWER AND A TECHNICAL QUESTION.
FOUR MINUTES YOU CAN DIVIDE IT
UP AS YOU LIKE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHEER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JOE Là MERIONETH I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF REACH
THINK WASTE WHICH IS A SOLID
WASTE.
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY ON THE
SAN FRANCISCO PENINSULA WE HAVE
TWELVE MEMBER AGENCIES BETWEEN
EAST PALO ALTO IN BURLINGAME --
AND WE ALSO INCLUDE THE COUNTY
OF SAN MATTEO IN A SANITARY
DISTRICT.
WE HAVE FIRST EXPERIENCE DEALING
WITH THE CATASTROPHIC EFFECTS OF
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES I'VE GOT
SEVERAL EXAMPLES HERE -- OF THE
THE GROWING CONCERN HERE THIS IS
THIS IS THE BEFORE THIS IS THE
AFTER -- WHEN THESE MATERIALS
ARE NOT HANDLED RESPONSIBLY --
THEY CAN.
GO INTO THE HIGHLY MECHANIZED
EQUIPMENT THAT WE USE TO SORT
AND PROCESS MATERIALS -- AT THAT
TIME IT'S VERY COMMON FOR THAT
TO GO IN BETWEEN -- THE
MECHANIZED EQUIPMENT AND THE THE
SAFETY.
SAFETY COATINGS ARE BREACHED AND
FIRE COMES OUT SO WE HAD AN
EIGHT AND A HALF MILLION DOLLAR
FIRE ON SEPTEMBER SEVENTH OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE PLANT WAS
CLOSED FOR ALMOST FOUR MONTHS.
IT TOOK ABOUT A YEAR TO GET BACK
ON TRACK -- DURING THAT TIME
ABOUT FIFTY WORKERS WERE
FURLOUGHED DURING THE HOLIDAYS
WHICH IS VERY AND FORTUNE I AM
VERY HAPPY TO SAY NO ONE WAS
INJURED.
THEY FOLLOWED THE EVACUATION.
PROCEDURES TO A TEE SO ONCE THEY
REALIZE THE FIRE GOT AWAY FROM
THEM THEY THEY GOT OUT OF THE
PLANT WHICH WAS AMAZING -- BUT
MORE TO THE POINT -- NOT ONLY IS
THERE A WORKER SAFETY ISSUE
INVOLVED BUT THE FACILITY ITSELF
IS AT RISK AT SERIOUS RISK SO
FOR US -- OR INSURANCE PROVIDER --
WORKED WITH US RIGHT TO THE END
THEY PAID EVERYTHING THEY WERE
OBLIGATED TO DO AND THEN THEY
FIRED US.
THEY FIRED AS THEY WALKED AWAY
THEY SAID WE'RE NOT GETTING IN
THIS CATEGORY OF COVERAGE
ANYMORE.
SO WE NOW HAVE SEVEN INSURANCE
COMPANIES -- PROVIDING COVERAGE
WHERE WE HAD ONE BEFORE OUR
PREMIUMS HAVE TRIPLED OUR OUR
COVERAGE -- WILL BE VERY
CHALLENGING IF THIS WERE TO
HAPPEN AGAIN LET ME TELL YOU.
SO I DEFINITELY WANT TO ASSURE
YOU THAT WE'VE TAKEN MANY MANY --
I INTERNAL STEPS WITHIN THE
FACILITY TO IMPLEMENT -- FIRE
SUPPRESSION EQUIPMENT HIGHER
LEVEL OF TRAINING ECCENTRICITY
WERE MORE PREPARED IF AND WHEN
THIS HAPPENS IN THE FUTURE.
BUT THE THE KEY POINT IS WITH
THE PROLIFERATION OF LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES IN OUR MODERN SOCIETY --
WE ARE SEEING A VERY STEEP
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF THESE
MATERIALS THAT WE GET IN OUR
FACILITIES AND PUTTING OUR
WORKERS AT RISK AND THE FACILITY
AT RISK SO -- WE JUST DID A
COUNTY AND IT'S LITERALLY
DOUBLED FROM A YEAR AGO -- WE'RE
CURRENTLY GETTING ELEVEN
BATTERIES AND OUR EVERYONE OF
THESE REPRESENTS A COMBUSTIBLE
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THE BEING ON OUR SIDE OF THE
FENCE -- IT'S TIME FOR ACTION
WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT SO -- WILL NOT ONLY THREE
MINUTES.
THE MAY PASS WE SHOULD HAVE TIME
FOR THE OTHER WITNESS YES.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AT JASON SMELTER HERE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS YOU'RE
CHIEF.
MAKE A COUPLE OF OBSERVATIONS AM
J. O. ALREADY GAVE YOU A REAL
LIFE EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS IS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM AND FOCUS ON
WHAT'S IN THE BILL OKAY.
AB FIFTEEN OR NINE ESSENTIALLY
ESTABLISHES A WITH THE MY ON
RECYCLING PROGRAM INSIDE CAL
RECYCLE IT TREATS LOOSE
BATTERIES AND BATTERIES THAT ARE
EMBEDDED INSIDE OF A PRODUCT A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY -- FOR
BATTERIES INSIDE OF A PRODUCT TO
CREATE MULTIPLE PATHWAYS
COMPLIANCE FOR THESE BATTERIES
IT DOESN'T EXTENDED PRODUCE
RESPONSIBILITY PROBLEM.
BOTH OF THESE KIND OF FALL UNDER
THE GUISE OF PRODUCER SPOTS
ABILITY AND I WANTED VERY
QUICKLY MAKE THE CASE FOR WHY.
MANUFACTURERS SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS PARTICULAR
OUTCOME.
IF YOU REMEMBER WE'VE BEEN HERE
BEFORE EPR ESSENTIALLY FOCUSES
ON PRODUCTS THAT AT THE END OF
LIFE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT AND OF
LIFE IMPACT FALLING OF BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES --
ENVIRONMENTAL LIKE MERCURY
THERMOSTATS PUBLIC HEALTH LIKE
DRUGS AND SHARPS OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH LIKE SHARPS I
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT COSTS LIKE
MATTRESSES AND CARPET THINGS
LIKE THAT.
VIEW MY A BATTERIES FRANKLY
CHECK A BUNCHOF THE DIFFERENT
BOXES HERE IT'S NOT CONDITIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH HAZARD LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COSTA SIGNIFICANTLY
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGES IS PRETTY.
INCREDIBLE WHEN THESE FACILITIES
BURNHAM AND THAT ALL THAT STUFF --
WE FEEL PRETTY STRONGLY ABOUT
THIS BILL WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT
AND I DO WANT TO MENTION THE
OPPOSITION LETTERS VERY QUICKLY
NOT FOR WHAT THEY SAY ALTHOUGH
I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND ANYTHING
THAT THEY DO SAY BUT THERE'S
THREE THINGS VERY VERY
SPECIFICALLY THAT.
THEY DO NOT SAY.
THE LETTERS DO NOT SAY THAT THE
BATTERIES.
ARE NOT DANGEROUS.
THEY DO NOT SAY THAT THEIR
PRODUCTS ARE NOT STARTING THESE
FIRES AND THEY DO NOT SAY THAT
THEY SHOULDN'T BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE OUTCOME OF
THOSE FIRES SO WE WOULD SAY.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON A. B. FIFTEEN
OH NINE HAPPY ANSWERING
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OF OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ABOUT THIS OF CALIFORNIANS WASTE
WERE ACTUALLY CO SPONSORING THE
BILL THE PREVIOUS TWO SPEAKERS
AND OUR DRIVER THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON GREEN I'M
WITH SANITATION DISTRICTS OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE ALSO HAVE
FACILITIES SIMILAR TO RETHINK
WASTE AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS AND SUPPORT.
PERSONAL KIDDOS HERE ON BEHALF
OF STOP WASTE WESTERN CLASS OR
WASTE MANAGEMENT THIRTY AND
SOLID WASTE OF STATION OF NORTH
AMERICA IN SUPPORT.
FOREIGN COMMON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL
COUNTIES WE HAVE A SUPPORT IN
CONCEPT POSITION.
WE APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS
RAISED IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
WITH RESPECT TO HOW THE PROGRAM
WOULD OPERATE AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHORS ON THOSE PROGRAM
MECHANICS AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANY DEPOSIT BASE SYSTEM WORKS
FOR CONSUMERS WHERE IT'S EASY
FOR CONSUMERS TO GET THEIR MONEY
BACK.
AS EASY AS IT IS TO PAY INTO
PROGRAM IN THE FIRST PLACE SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NOW WITH THE
OPPOSITION LIKE TO COME FORWARD
AND STATE THEIR CONCERNS.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS SCOTT
GOVERNOR BEHALF OF P. R. BA THE
RECHARGEABLE BATTERY ASSOCIATION.
OUR LETTER WAS CERTAINLY LATE SO
IT'S NOT OUR INTENT TO GET INTO
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF DETAIL
TODAY.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
AUTHORS PLURAL TO TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
MECHANICS OF THE BILL.
AND OTHER THINGS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
POSITION EMILY PAPPAS FOR H. P.
INK WE'VE BEEN A STEWARD AND
BATTERY TAKE BACK FOR FOR BEFORE
A CAR WAS A THING WHEN WE LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
AND AND HIS STAFF OF AS WE HAVE
BEEN SINCE DAY ONE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SCENE NINE GREAT MISTER DALI.
FIRST OWNERS THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS EITHER THIS IS A PROBLEM
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO JUSTICE
ISSUE -- I DID HAVE A BATTERY
IRON WITHIN BATTERY LAST YEAR
AND SOMEWHERE ALONG THE SAME
LINES I JUST KIND OF CAN YOU
GIVE ME AN IDEA OF HOW IT'S
GONNA BE IMPLEMENTED I DID FOR
ME SO -- WHEN WE HAVE THE EVEN
THE?
C. R. V. RETURN AND AND THE ONE
SIZE DOESN'T REALLY FIT ALL IN
SOME OF THE AREAS ESPECIALLY THE
VERY RURAL AREAS OF CALIFORNIA.
A SIR CAN YOU CAN JUST GIVE ME
AN IDEA.
OF WHAT YOUR WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
ARE AND HOW WOULD LOOK FOR THE
THE PROGRAM TO ACTUALLY BE
IMPLEMENTED THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MADAM MY GOAL HERE IS NOT TO BE
OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE BUT TO
PROVIDE A MENU OF OPTIONS TO
SORT OF COMPLY WITH.
WITH THIS THING THIS A
COMPLICATED -- AREA.
OF PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION BUT I
WOULD LIKE -- TO BRING JASON IF
HE CAN JUST TALK GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTING A PROGRAM.
ABSOLUTELY.
SEE YOU AND TALK INTO THE MIKE
AT THE SAME TIME -- EPR PROGRAMS
IN THE BUT THE BATTERY RECYCLING
PROGRAM AT ALTERNATELY BE THICK
PART OF PART OF A PLAN THAT'S
APPROVED BY CAL RECYCLE AND IN
THOSE PLANS THEY ESSENTIALLY GO
BACK AND SHOW HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO DEVELOP APPROPRIATE COVERAGE
FOR THE STATE.
SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
COMPANIES IN THEIR STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM TO PLAN -- FOR JUST LIKE
THEY DO ON THE EXISTING PROGRAMS
WE HAVE HAD SOME ISSUES WITH
THESE PROGRAMS IN THE PAST.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS THERE IS --
WERE LEARNING -- AND WE'RE
LEARNING HOW TO WORK AROUND SOME
OF THESE PROBLEMS WERE
DEVELOPING THE BILLS AND THAT'S
WHAT OUR INTENT IS HERE.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SO -- MISS MULLIN AND YOU CLOSE
FOR WE HAVE A LIST OF
OUTSTANDING ISSUES ON PAGE SIX
AND SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS.
I WON'T ASK YOU TO READ THROUGH
THEM ALL NOW -- BUT I ASSUME YOU
AND YOUR STAFF OF LOOKED AT THEM --
AS A SERIES OF YESES NOTED ON
THE ID AND ALICE'S WHICH I THINK
IS A GOOD SIGN THEIR NUMBER OF
ISSUES RAISED RIGHT ON THAT WE
THINK.
WE ARE WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WE
CAN PROPERLY.
ADDRESS YOU CAN REALLY THIS IS
THIS IS MOTIVATED MISTER CHAIR
BY A RECOGNITION THAT THE STATUS
QUO IS UNACCEPTABLE THAT SAFETY
IS AT RISK.
ARM AND THIS IS ABOUT -- NOT
ONLY DISCONCERTED A STATEWIDE
CONCERN AND A AND A CLEAR --
MISSION IN THE WAY WE DEAL WITH
THESE THINGS THAT'S RESULTING IN
FIRES AND IT'S GOING TO BE AN
INCREASING PROBLEM SO.
I'LL BUT IN TERMS OF THAT SOME
OF THE DETAILS I IDENTIFIED IN
THE ANALYSIS I'M CONFIDENT WE
CAN ADDRESS.
VIRTUALLY ALL OF THOSE CONCERNS.
ISSUES RAISED GOING FORWARD
[inaudible]
GOOD -- AS WITH THE A LOT OF
BILLS WE DON'T EXPECT THEM TO BE
PERFECT IN THE FIRST COMMITTEE --
ISSUES ARE RAISED AND THEY TAKE
TIME TO WORK OUT -- SO I THINK
THOUGH THAT THE BIGGEST PROBLEM.
EVEN WHEN YOU HAVE ONE IS GOING
TO BE GETTING THE PUBLIC TO
COMPLY -- BECAUSE TO REFER TO
NOT HAVE THESE FIRES YOU'RE
GONNA NEED.
MUCH BETTER COMPLIANCE THAN WE
HAVE WITH OTHER PROGRAMS AND YOU
KNOW MAYBE WE SHOULD BE HAVING
SOME SORT OF A AND AGAIN.
I'M JUST TALKING HERE -- BUT
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO NEED TO HAVE -- ADVERTISING --
NOT UP PERHAPS LOOKING AT ALL
THE BATTERY PROGRAMS -- TOGETHER
SINCE.
SINCE THEY ALL HAVE THEIR OWN
SET OF ISSUES BUT THIS IS ONE
THAT CERTAINLY KEY BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT MORE FIRES IN.
RISKING OF HELP OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S SEE WE HAVE A
MOTION.
AS FROM MISTER.
LET'S SEE ABOUT.
FROM OUR QUE HAN SECOND BYE.
BYE KALRA -- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
FIFTEEN OH NINE MULLIN.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES QUIRK AYE
QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ KALRA.
KALRA I BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY NOT VOTING CRISTINA GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
THIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING TO CHANGE WHAT
I TO GI.
IT HAS FOUR ONE MILLION -- ONE
MORE.
THANKS SIR.
WE ARE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
CAN CAN.
MISTER KALRA.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL
.
SO THIS IS AB SIX FOUR SEVEN
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS HAS MEDIC
SAFETY DOCUMENTS -- AND MR OUR
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AB SIX FORTY SEVEN FORTY
TODAY.
SB SIX FORTY SEVEN REQUIRE
COSMETIC AND DISINFECT
MANUFACTURES WHO ALREADY ARE
REQUIRED UNDER CURRENT LAW. TO
CREATE IMPROVISING TO DATA
SHEETS TO DO SO ONLINE AND
TRANSLATED DEPARTMENT LANGUAGES
SPOKEN BY SOMEONE PROFESSIONALS.
SB DATA SHEET IS A DOCUMENT THAT
IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE INFORMATION ABOUT
A SUBSTANCE OR MIXTURE FOR USE
IN WORKPLACE CHEMICAL MANAGEMENT.
AND REQUIRED TO BE PRESENTED IN
A USER FRIENDLY FORMAT.
AS YOU MAY KNOW CURRENT FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW REQUIRES MANY
FACTORS CRITICISM HE DID AS SHE
AND DISTRIBUTE THEM TO SALONS.
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE USED AS A
SOURCE OF INFORMATION ABOUT
HAZARDS INCLUDING ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS AND TO OBTAIN ADVICE ON
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS.
SOMEONE INDUSTRY EMPLOYS MANY
WOMEN OF COLOR AND IMMIGRANTS
RIGHT A DISADVANTAGE WHEN IT
COMES TO ACCESS OF INFORMATION.
THEY ALSO HIRE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS IS NON EMPLOYEE
STATUS MAY DENY THEM THE RIGHT
TO DEMAND A SEPARATE DATA SHEET.
WHICH LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO
ACCESS OF INFORMATION AS WELL.
CB DID DID ISSUES ARE CURRENTLY
PRODUCED IN HARD COPY FORM AND
MAY ONLY BE AVAILABLE IN ENGLISH
WHICH CAN MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
MANY SLAM RECORD ACCESS TO DO A
LANGUAGE BARRIER OR THE DOCUMENT
GETTING LOST MONTHS OTHER SAFETY
DATA SHEETS.
SB SIX FORTY SUBMIT ONLY REQUIRE
MANY FACTORS THAT ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED BY CURRENT LAW TO
CREATE A SAFETYDATA SHEET TO
POST ONLINE AND OF THOSE
REQUIRED BY LAW ALREADY TO
CREATIVITY SHEET. TO POST ONLINE
AND TRANSLATE INTO THE MOST
COMMON LANGUAGES SPOKEN BUT THIS
ONE WORKERS.
BY ALLOWING STUPIDITY SHEETS TO
BE ACCESSIBLE ONLINE INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY AND REYES A SAFETY
AWARENESS TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH
AND WORKING CONDITIONS FOR SALON
PROFESSIONALS.
ALTHOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED CONCERNS MINISTRY
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR SALON
PROFESSIONALS HAVE ACCESS TO CP
DATASHEETS AS WELL AS OUR
CUSTOMERS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE NEW
DATA SHE'S TO BE CREATED BY SOME
POSSIBLY ASK MANUFACTURE
SUPPOSED TO SAY PETITIONS ONLINE
AND TRANSLATE AND UPON OF
LANGUAGES.
CALMLY SPOKEN BY SALON BROKERS
AS THE BILL MOVES FLORIDA
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION
SURROUNDED THEIR CONCERNS BRING
CLARITY TO THE BILL.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TEST MONEY ARE CATHERINE PORTER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH A
HEALTHY MEALS LONG COLLABORATIVE
AND LOCK NGUYEN NAIL SALON
WORKER AND TRANSLATE PEARL BE.
YOUNG WHEN THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO IF YOU COULD TAKE A
TWO MINUTES ARE FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WILL ALLOW TWO MINUTES
IN [inaudible]
OUR THE NATIVE LANGUAGE FOR THE
SECOND -- PERSON AND WE WON'T
COUNT THE TRANSLATION TOWARDS
THE TIME.
GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN QUIRK AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I CAN'T I AM
CATHERINE PORTER THE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HELPING ELSE LONG COLLABORATIVE.
WE WORK TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH
SAFETY AND RIGHTS FOR THE
PREDOMINATELY VIETNAMESE
IMMIGRANT WORK FORCE NAIL SALONS.
OUR ORGANIZATION AND THE
ORGANISATION WORK SAFE ON WHOSE
BEHALF I ALSO SPEAK TODAY ARE
THE CO SPONSORS OF AB.
SIX FOUR SEVEN ACROSS CALIFORNIA
NAY ALLEN HERE SALON WORKERS
MANY OF WHOM ARE WOMEN OF
REPRODUCTIVE AGE.
HANDLE A RANGE OF DISINFECTANTS
AND COSMETIC PRODUCTS CONTAINING
CARCINOGENS CHEMICALS LINKED TO
REPRODUCTIVE RESPIRATORY AND
OTHER HARM.
UNDER EXISTING LAW LET MANUAL
LABOR LAW MANUFACTURES MUST
DEVELOP AND DISTRIBUTE HARD COPY
SAFETY DATA SHEETS FOR ANY
PRODUCT CONTAINING HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES.
THERE ULTIMATELY REQUIRED TO BE
AVAILABLE AT WORK PLACES AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE AND AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA SPOKE OUT ABOUT.
THESE HARD COPY DOCUMENTS CAN
THEY GET LOST IN THE LONG CHAIN
OF DISTRIBUTION FOR MANUFACTURED
TO OUR DISTRIBUTOR TO SUPPLY
STORE ULTIMATELY TO THE OWNER TO
HOPEFULLY.
THE WORKER THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS
HAPPEN -- COUNTY AND CITY
COORDINATORS OF LOOKING LOCAL
HEALTHY NAIL SALON RECOGNITION
PROGRAMS REPORT THAT THEY HAVE A
HARD TIME OBTAINING SAFETY DATA
SHEETS FROM MANUFACTURERS.
AS THEY TRY TO ASSIST NAIL
SALONS AND THESE ARE IN CENTER
OF LOCAL BASED PROGRAMS -- THEN
ONCE THEY'RE OBTAINED LANGUAGE
IS OFTEN A BARRIER TO THE SAFETY
AND HEALTH INFORMATION THEY
CONTAIN.
SO JUST TO REPEAT THE SB SIX
FOUR SEVEN ONLY REQUIRES TWO
THINGS.
WHERE MANUFACTURE ALREADY
CREATES A SAFETY DATA SHEET FOR
COSMETIC OR DISINFECTANT PUT IT
ONLINE?
THE OTHER IS.
TRANSLATE THOSE SAFETY DATA
SHEETS INTO THE LANGUAGE THAT
PREDOMINATE IN THE SALON
INDUSTRY WE BELIEVE THAT SOME IS
A MODEST AND REASONABLE ATTEMPT
TO SHINE MORE LIGHT ON THE
POTENTIAL HAZARDS OF COSMETICS
AND DISINFECTANTS.
USE EVERY DAY BY WOMEN SALON
WORKERS FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE A YES VOTE ON A. B. SIX
FOUR SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THINK OF ANYTHING BUT WHAT COULD
YOU BE CLOSER TO THE MICROPHONE.
THE DOUBLE THE THOUGHT THE LEVEL
YOU THOUGHT THE PICK NINETY
COATED.
HANG INCOME TO MOVE OFF THE
SUMMER.
I HAD MADE NOW MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LEFT
WING I EMIGRATE TO UNITED STATES
FROM VIETNAM IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN I WORK AS AS A MANICURIST
AT NATURAL NAIL PLUS A LONG AND
LIVE IN OAKLAND.
I WORKED IN THE US FUNDS FOR
FIVE YEARS.
LET ME NOW FUNNY AT THE WILL
CALL THEM AND THEN LET ME NINE
PP.
JOHN FOCUS HOPE.
I HOPE FOR HIM IN A BOOK TO GET
ALL THE COMING AROUND LET ME A
NAME AND SAY YEAH NUMBER BUT YOU
WANT TO CRY.
I STARTED WORKING AS A LINES
BECAUSE I HAD FRIENDS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS IN THE BUSINESS AND NEW
I CAN LEARN THE SKILLS TO DO A
GOOD JOB.
WHEN I DECIDE TO BE MANICURES I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT EVERY DAY I
WOULD WORK WITH HARMFUL
CHEMICALS? THIRTY NINE OF THE
TEN FALLING DOWN YEAH CAN OF BUT
THEY'LL CALL HOME WE CAN YOU
TELL US A NEW ONE THAT GOT SOME
SOME PARTICULAR CASE.
AND NAY.
AT WORK SOMETIMES I EXPERIENCE
HEADACHES SKIN RASHES WATERY
EYES TROUBLE BREATHING AND A
SORE THROAT WHICH MAY BE RELATED
TO THE PRODUCTS THAT I USE
[inaudible]
BUT KING KONG PROCLAIM COST NEW
COMPANY.
THEY CAN'T QUITE GET SOME SOME
FROM.
ONE ABOVE ANYTHING DIDN'T THE
PUNK WAS SO FULL NAME HI
[inaudible]
COME BANGKOK.
THEN I COME FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
FOOT UP NOT.
COULD YOU.
LAUGH.
KEEPING.
COMPILER THING MIGHT HAVE PUT
THE I KNOW THAT SAFETY DATA
SHEET HAVE A PORT INFORMATION
ABOUT THE CHEMICALS IN THE PARK
FOR USE AT WORK AND HOW TO
BETTER PROTECT MYSELF FROM
UNNECESSARY EXPOSURES.
BUT THEY'RE HARD TO OBTAIN AND
IT'S NOT EASY TO UNDERSTAND
EXPRESSION WHEN IT'S NOT IN MY
PRIMARY LANGUAGE.
WHEN SOMEONE TELL ME EIGHTEEN
PUMPKIN PIE WHAT THE FARM HIT
THE NET FOR CALLING USUALLY?
COME TO WITH THE IMPACT. NINE
BUT DOT COM THANK YOU BYE BYE SO
COME.
THE NIGHTFALL.
BUT MANDATE A MINUTE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EXECUTIVE TO WITHIN.
COULD YOU TELL ME WHAT THOUGHT
DON'T.
THANK YOU WELL.
ARE YOU CAN I GOT AN IDEA.
THEY SAID THEY THEY COULDN'T
TELL YOU DON'T HAVE A SOME OF MY
FAMILY.
THE PEOPLE WHO I KNOW LOOK FOR
SAFETY DATA SHEETS ON THE
INTERNET -- ASTERS ALIGN OWNER
AND FRIENDS AND I DO THE SAME SO
WHY NOT PUT SAFETY DATA SHEETS
THERE TO TO MAKE THEM EASIER TO
OBTAIN.
TRANSLATING THOSE DOCUMENTS INTO
VINNY'S ROOM WOULD MAKE THEM
EASIER FOR THE OWNER OF MY SALON
AND MICHAEL [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WITNESSES.
OUR OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CORBELS ON BEHALF
OF BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
AND BILL ALLEY -- FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT SPENCER WITH THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN IS DISTRICT
NINE IN SUPPORT.
WHICH DUGGAR WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
HI CHRISTY THE MOTHER BIRD SAID
ON BEHALF OF EDUCATE ADVOCATE
AND SUPPORT.
SHANNON PRIMER ON BEHALF OF
EMPOWER FAMILY CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
PLEASE A JUNE ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
HUNG NGUYEN FROM SAN JOSE -- ON
BEHALF OF MY WIFE WHO IS THE
NASSAU OWN OWNER SEE COULDN'T
GET THE MSTS AND COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND IF.
SO I'M HERE TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY NEW WHERE VERNE
WHEN WITH ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES
TO OUR SUPPORT.
I AM FROM ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES
IN OAKLAND A SUPPORTED EIGHTY
FIFTH [inaudible]
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THE IN IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
I AM WILL KERR IN NOW SO LONG.
AS THE BALK A. B..
SIX OF FOUR SEVEN PLEASE THE
BOSS YES.
ON A. B. SIX FOUR SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO ANYBODY.
HI HOW YOU.
MY NAME ONLY.
BOTH LIMON PROFILE -- BILL I'M
NOW UPLAND.
BUT WHAT DID YOU LOOK THE ABBE
SHOVEL WHITE.
MY NAME IS NO FOUR FIVE I AM IN
NO SONG WILL GO FROM OPENING I
SUPPORTED SB.
SIX FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THIRTY NINE ELEVEN TO VOTE
ON NAY NOW OPEN THREE M..
FROM HOME YOU LOOKS SALAMONE BY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LET THEM I AM ENOUGH
ALONG WHAT GOOD FROM OAKLAND.
I SUPPORTED A. B. TO FIX FOR THE
SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI AM I YOU LAND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HELPING ELSE ONE
COLLABORATIVE AND I SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN QUIRK
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KAREN ROSS I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL THE LEADING TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE INDUSTRY.
WITH OVER A HUNDRED MEMBER
COMPANIES LOCATED IN STATE --
WHILE WELL INTENDED WE'RE HERE
TO OPPOSE AB SIX FOUR SEVEN
UNLESS AMENDED -- BASED ON THE
EARLIER TESTIMONY I JUST WANT TO
BEGIN BY STATING THAT INDUSTRY
BELIEVES THAT -- SAFETY DATA
SHEET SHOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE
TO EVERY SALON WORKER AN
EMPLOYEE ON THEY SHOULD NOT BE
HARD TO ATTAIN -- IT IS FEDERAL
LAW THAT THEY SHOULD BE REQUIRED --
AND MANY OF OUR MANUFACTURERS
CURRENTLY PUBLISH THEM ONLINE
AND IN SEVERAL LANGUAGES -- ALSO
START BY JUST SAYING THAT OUR
INDUSTRY HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
INGREDIENT TRANSPARENCY I JUST
LAST YEAR WE WORKED WITH -- IS
SIMPLY MEMBER KALRA ON AND I AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FIVE THAT BILL
MANDATES THE DISCLOSURE OF
INGREDIENTS FOR PROFESSIONAL
PRODUCTS USED IN SALONS.
IT MAKES THE IDENTICAL
REQUIREMENTS TO INGREDIENT
TRANSPARENCY THAT'S CURRENTLY
PROVIDED FOR COSMETICS PROVIDED
AT RETAIL SALE -- AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN PC PC BELIEVES ON THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL IS A LITTLE
UNCLEAR -- SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
IN IT IS VAGUE ON THE SAFETY
DATA SHEETS SHOULD -- ARE
INTENDED FOR USE BY WORKPLACE
PROFESSIONALS EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL POISON CONTROL CENTERS
I'M NOT CONSUMERS SO THE
LANGUAGE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
CLARIFIED -- BECAUSE IT'S
UNCLEAR RIGHT NOW WHETHER IT'S
GOING TO BE MANDATED FOR
PROFESSIONAL YEARS AND RETAIL
SALE CUTS MAX -- THE FORMAT AND
THE CONTENT OF THE S. TO GAS IS
JUST NOT SOMETHING THAT'S FOR
CONSUMER USE AS FOR OCCUPATIONAL
USE.
SECONDLY WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL -- PROVIDING A SEPARATE SDS
SHEET -- FOR EVERY DIFFERENT
SHADE AND COLOUR OF PRODUCT --
IN OUR VIEW IS UNNECESSARY SO
THE SAFETY DATA PROFILE DOES NOT
CHANGE BASED ON A SHADE OR COLOR
AND SO YOU COULD HAVE ONE
MANUFACTURER WITH ONE PRODUCT
WITH ONE SAFETY PROFILE WITH
HUNDREDS OF VARIATIONS IN COLOR
OR SHADE.
AND SO IT'S OUR OPINION THAT WE
THINK PROVIDED HAVING TO PRINT --
DUPLICATE AND ASKED YES FOR
EVERY DIFFERENT SHADE IS
UNNECESSARY I'M AND DOESN'T EVEN
PROVIDE ANY ADDED BENEFIT -- TO
WORKER SO -- FOR ALL OF THOSE
REASONS WERE OPPOSED TO AB SIX
FOUR SEVEN ON UNLESS A MAN DEAD --
WE DO APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALL ARE LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE
AS I MENTIONED YOU KNOW OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES DO EVERYTHING
BASED ON SOUND SCIENCE --
INGREDIENT TRANSPARENCY AND ARE
PROVIDING PRODUCTS -- TO SALONS
AND SPAS AROUND THE COUNTRY SO
WE SUPPORT MAKING SURE THAT
WORKERS HAVE ADEQUATE --
INFORMATION ON THE PRODUCTS THAT
THEY USE THANK YOU FOR A TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON A COOKING AS A
BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
WE ALSO HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION PARTICULARLY.
ON THE INCLUSION OF
DISINFECTANTS WE HAVE OFFERED
LANGUAGE WHERE WE REQUEST TO
NARROW THE DEFINITION OF
DISINFECTANT SO IT'S AS SPECIFIC
TO PRODUCTS THAT ARE LABELED FOR
USE ON TOOLS USED IN A SALON --
OUR INDUSTRY IS SORT OF USED TO
HAVING REGULATED BY WHAT IS ON
LABEL I'M OUR PRODUCTS ARE
APPROVED BY THE US EPA AND THEN
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION FOR SAFETY AND
EFFICACY -- SO CAN APPRECIATE
WHAT THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS ARE
ARE HOPING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
UNIVERSE -- IS SPECIFIC TO WHAT
IT WOULD BE USED IN SALONS AND
NOT SORT OF TRIGGER -- ALL
PROFESSIONAL DISINFECTANTS THAT
COULD BE USED IN A AND A BROAD --
APPLICATIONS OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- MR NOW LET'S SEE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE YES
MISTER DALI.
SO UP PER SE BRING THE BILL FORD
AS SOMEBODY WHO.
HAS WORKED THROUGH THE EVOLUTION
OF THE MSTS.
LAWS FOR THE LAST THIRTY YEARS
QUITE FRANKLY -- SO I I WANT TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY -- BUT I
AM A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS ABOUT
TIME I DON'T THINK IT'S A
PROBLEM TO REPORT IN LANGUAGE
THAT TO IT SO THERE'S SOME
BROADNESS IN YOUR BILL.
NUMBER.
ONE HOW MANY LANGUAGES ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT I DO I MEAN THAT'S
HASN'T REALLY BEEN DEFINED AND I
KNOW THAT.
VIETNAMESE AND I MEAN WE HAD
SEVERAL BILLS IN THE PAST -- AND
I WANT TO THE WORK FORCE TO BE
ABLE TO ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND.
THE PRODUCTS THEY USE EVERYDAY
NUMBER ONE NUMBER -- TWO AND
THEN THE DEFINITION OF
COMMERCIAL -- AND THEN ALSO A
NON COMMERCIAL SO -- THOSE ARE
THE TWO AREAS THAT I'M A LITTLE
BIT CONCERNED ABOUT BUT I THE
FORT OF SUPPORTING A REAL
HEALTHY YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THOSE.
SO WE GET THERE.
UNTIL I HAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
THANK YOU SUMMER DOLLY
ABSOLUTELY -- BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS BILL.
GOES FORWARD AS INTENDED WAS
REALLY JUST PROVIDE INFORMATION
TO THOSE THAT ARE WORKING -- BUT
WE IN THESE LINES TO THAT -- AND
MORE SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR
QUESTION WE ACTUALLY LIVE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGES SO IT'S NOT
BROAD BASE AND HAVE TO BE
TRANSLATED UNDER DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES REALLY WERE TRYING TO
FOCUS ALL LANGUAGES.
THAT ARE MOST PREDOMINANT -- BUT
IN THE INDUSTRY ENGLISH
OBVIOUSLY IS ALREADY THERE ARE
BEING DONE SPANISH VIETNAMESE
CHINESE AND KOREAN.
AND SO -- BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IF WE DON'T SPECIFY THAT IS
GOOD IT COULD POTENTIALLY BE
OVERLY BURDENSOME ON INDUSTRY
AND AS A INDICATOR EARLIER --
AND ACTUALLY EVEN INDICATE ABOUT
OPPOSITION -- NOT ONLY OF THESE
ISSUES ALREADY BEING CREATED BUT
MANY THE COMPANY'S ALREADY
PUBLISHING THEM ONLINE AND SOME
ARE TRANSLATING AS WELL.
AND SO THE BUT IT'S NOT ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL WORK TO BE DONE
EXCEPT FOR THE ACTUAL
TRANSLATION WHICH PRESUMABLY
WOULD HAVE TO BE DONE ONE TIME
OR MAYBE TOUCHED UP ON OCCASION
TO UPDATE IT -- BUT IT AND IT IS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED FOR THOSE
THAT ARE WORKING IN THE SALONS
NOT BIRD YOU YOU AND I THAT WALK
IN AND AND AND AND BECAUSE THE
LANGUAGE IS.
GEARED TOWARDS THOSE ARE THE
PROFESSIONALS THAT DEAL WITH
THESE PRODUCTS EVERY DAY AND SO
THE IDEA REALLY IS THAT WORKER
SAFETY AND I THINK THAT.
BY THAT SALON WORKER HAVING
GREATER INFORMATION OF COURSE
THAT CREATES A BETTER CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE BOB BECAUSE THEY ALL
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE USING.
HAND UP ALSO TO THE FOR THE
COMMENT MY POSITION ON THE
DISINFECTANTS WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OPPOSITION TO CLARIFY
THAT AS WELL AND THEN ALSO ON
THE COLOR LIKE IT IF IT DOESN'T
MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO THERE'S TO
NEVER COLORS I MEAN.
THEY WITH THIS THE JANICE IS OF
THE CHEMICALS PROBABLY CLOSE THE
SAME I'M ASSUMING THAT ON OF
THAT CREDIT OR GIVE.
KATHY MITCHELL YEAH I THINK
THERE'S A MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT
THE BILL THE BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANYTHING BEYOND WHAT'S
ALREADY.
IT.
HOW THE BILL READS -- AND MAYBE
WE SHOULD CLARIFY THIS IS IF
THERE ARE SEPARATE SAFETY DEED
DATA SHEETS CREATED. FOUR
DIFFERENT COLORS THAN THOSE ALSO
HAVE TO BE PUT ON A WEBSITE.
SO AGAIN DOES NOT CREATE.
ANY NEW OBLIGATION -- TO TO
DEVELOP SAFETY DATA SHEETS IT
DOES REQUIRE THEM TO CREATE
SEPARATE DATA SHEETS IT DOES IT
IS SHE'S ALREADY BY LOBBYING
CREATED.
THAT REQUIRES AN OPOSSUM
SEPARATELY SO IT'S EASIER TO
FOLLOW.
AND WE'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION
TO CLARIFY THAT AS WELL AS WITH
YOUR OFFICE ANYONE ELSE WELL I'M
READING I'M LOOKING AT THE BILL
RIGHT HERE.
THE LANGUAGE IT SAYS BIT SO
SEPARATE MSTS BASED ON COLOR OR
TENT.
AS IN NAIL POLISHES HAIR DYE AND
OTHER COSMETICS SO THEY MUST
ALREADY HAVE AN MSTS READY IS
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING JUST ITEM
TRANSLATE INTO THEM FOR LUNCH
OKAY.
FINE WHICH HELP CLARIFY THAT
BECAUSE IT IS A IT CAN BE.
A LITTLE CONFUSING IF IF UP READ --
AND SO IF THERE'S A OPPORTUNITY
TO CLARIFY IT FOR THEIR HAPPY TO
DO THAT.
A MOVE THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT TO THE BILL IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED -- MISTER
KALRA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AND ALSO TO RESPOND TO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION.
NO I I I APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION'S WORKING WITH US AND
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS OR
RAISE I THINK THAT MY RESPONSES --
I HOPE ADEQUATELY ANSWER THEM
BUT WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION AS WELL AS ANY
OTHER MEMBERS HAVE FURTHER
QUESTIONS RESPECTFULLY ASK.
OKAY AND THEN YOU ALSO MADE
CLEAR THAT THIS IS FOR
COMMERCIAL.
NOT FOR THE AVERAGE CONSUMER WHO
HAS MUCH LESS OF AN EXPOSURE.
THAT IS CORRECT ALL RIGHT --
MADAM SECRETARY YOU MAY CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SIX
FORTY SEVEN KALRA THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
MELENDEZ.
KALRA [inaudible]
CALLER I BAUER-KAHAN
[inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DALY AYE [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MATHIS.
MATH IS NOT VOTING RIGHTS TO
CHANGE.
HERE SINCE FOR VOTE YOU HAVE
MORE.
WE'LL GET ONE MORE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU PLEASE COME
FORWARD
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THIS IS
COMMITTEE THAT KNOWS FULL WELL
HOW UNACCEPTABLE IT IS THAT IN
THE YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN WE
STILL HAVE TOO MANY COMMUNITIES
IN OUR STATE AND OVER A MILLION
RESIDENTS WHO LACK ACCESS TO
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
THIS IS A BILL THAT ADDRESSES
THE FACT THAT IN MANY YEARS OF
THE STATE THERE ARE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS I CAN'T AFFORD TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE PROVISION
OF SAFE DRINKING WATER.
THAT HAVE A DEFICIENCY IN
TECHNICAL MANAGERIAL OR
FINANCIAL CAPACITY DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WERE CONTAMINATED
DRINKING.
THESE ARE SYSTEMS THAT ARE OFTEN
NEAR OR NEXT TO LARGER WATER
SYSTEMS THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE HE
KNEW WATER DISTRICT.
WHILE THE CONSOLIDATION OF WATER
SYSTEMS CAN ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIANS IN NEIGHBORING
AREAS RECEIVE CLEAN WATER. FOR
WATER SYSTEMS REGULATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE APPROVAL PROCESS
CAN BE UNDULY TIME CONSUMING IN
SOME INSTANCES APPROVAL CAN TAKE
AS LONG AS SIXTEEN MONTHS EVEN
AFTER.
A STRONG MAJORITY OF RESIDENTS
VOTE TO CONSOLIDATE THEIR SYSTEM
WITH A NEIGHBORING UTILITY.
IT'S A CPU SEES OBLIGATION TO
REVIEW CONSOLIDATIONS
EFFICIENTLY IN ORDER TO PROTECT
CUSTOMERS BUT WE ALL KNOW THAT
THE LONGER REVIEW TAKES THE
LONGER WE HAVE RESIDENTS WERE
LEFT WITHOUT.
A CLEAN DRINKING WATER WE NEED
TO BOTH PROTECT EXISTING REPAIRS
AND DELIVER CLEAN WATER TO NEW
CUSTOMERS THIS BILL WOULD IMPOSE
FLEXIBLE DEADLINES ON THE CPC
FOR CONSOLIDATION APPROVAL. TO
ENSURE THAT THE CPC CAN HELP
IMPLEMENT OUR STATE'S OBJECTIVES
OF PROVIDING CLEAN DRINKING
WATER WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MY WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS THAT WERE JACKSON I'M
APPEARING TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THE
CALIFORNIA WATER SO SHE SHOULD.
I'M ASSOCIATION SECOND VICE
PRESIDENT 420-192-2020.
I'M ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF RATES
AND READ THE TERRY AFFAIRS FOR
LIBERTY UTILITIES WEST REGION.
IN THIS CAPACITY I'M RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE REGULATORY APPROVALS ON
ALL CONSOLIDATION APPLICATIONS.
MADE BY MY COMPANY TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
CURRENTLY LIBERTY UTILITIES HAS
TO CONSOLIDATION APPLICATIONS
BEFORE THE CPUC ONE WAS FILED IN
APRIL TWENTY SEVENTEEN FOLLOWING
A COMMISSION DECISION IN JANUARY
OF THAT YEAR.
DIRECTING A TROUBLED SMALL WATER
SYSTEM IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO
BE ACQUIRED BY LIBERTY.
THE SECOND APPLICATION WAS FILED
IN MAY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FOLLOWING AN ELECTION WHERE MORE
THAN 60% OF THE VOTING RESIDENTS
OF PARIS CALIFORNIA.
ELECTED TO HAVE THE CITY CELLS
TROUBLED WATER SYSTEM TO LIBERTY.
NEITHER OF THESE PENDING
APPLICATIONS ARE ANYWHERE NEAR
COMPLETION.
IN ADDITION LIBERTY UTILITIES AT
THE REQUEST OF BOTH THE CPUC IN
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
ACQUIRED THE URINAL WATER
COMPANY IN TWENTY FIFTEEN A
WATER SYSTEM NEAR BARSTOW THAT
HAD BEEN ABANDONED WAS IN
RECEIVERSHIP.
AND HAD FAILED AS A COMMUNITY
SERVICE DISTRICT.
ALSO LIBERTIES CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SOLICITATION PROCESS FOR
THE RIGHT TO CONSOLIDATE THE
CITY OF A WATER DISTRICT.
WHICH WAS THE SUBJECT OF
CONSOLIDATION LEGISLATION A. B.
FIFTEEN SEVEN SEVEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT BROUGHT THAT
TROUBLED SYSTEM UNDER THE
TEMPORARY CONTROL THE COUNTY.
CW A VERY MUCH APPRECIATES THE
EFFORTS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
AND TAKING ON THIS BILL.
AS YOU JUST NOTED THE APPROVAL
PROCESS AT THE CPC CAN BE UNDULY
TIME CONSUMING.
AND A BALANCE IS NEEDED BETWEEN
THE CPC'S RESPONSIBILITY FOR
APPROPRIATE REVIEW OF
CONSOLIDATION APPLICATIONS.
AND THE CUSTOMER'S NEED FOR SAFE
AND RELIABLE DRINKING WATER.
IN PART THE DELAYS ARE
STRUCTURAL NATURE BECAUSE THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AT THE CPC
BEGINS WITH AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
TIMELINE FOR DETAILED LEGAL
PROCEEDING.
USUALLY THE WATER UTILITIES
APPLICATION IS COMPLETE.
BUT OFTEN THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE WHICH PROCESSES THE
APPLICATION FOR THE CPC.
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL DATA AND
INFORMATION PRINCIPALLY FOR TWO
REASONS.
CONCERNS OVER PURCHASE PRICE.
AND CONCERNS OVER POTENTIAL RATE
IMPACTS ON THE UTILITIES
EXISTING CUSTOMERS.
THIS ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS CAN
TAKE MONTHS TO COMPLETE.
CONSTRAINTS THE COMMISSION
RESOURCES THAT IMPEDE FASTER
APPROVAL TIMES.
INCLUDE THE VOLUME OF ENERGY
RELATED WORK.
THE SUBORDINATION OF WATER
ISSUES TO ENERGY ISSUES.
AND THE JOURNAL WORKLOAD ON CPC
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES.
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES CAM
CONTRIBUTING TO DELAYS MAY
INCLUDE THE APPLICATION MAY BE
INCOMPLETE.
THE COMMISSION MAY INSIST ON
REVISED VALUATION OUR APPRAISAL
OF THE SYSTEM BEING ACQUIRED.
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
ASSIGN COMMISSIONERS MAY BE
CHANGED IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PROCEEDING.
THERE MAY BE DISPUTES OVER THE
VALUE OF WATER RIGHTS HELD BY
THE SYSTEM BEING ACQUIRED.
PLUS MANY OTHER PROCEDURAL AND
SUBSTANTIVE ISSUES MAY ARISE.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE WILL
ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS BY
CHANGING THE STARTING POINT FOR
AN APPLICATION FROM EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO EIGHT MONTHS.
IF YOU BEGIN WITH EIGHT MONTHS
ALL STAKEHOLDERS WILL BE
INCENTIVIZE TO BE MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THE CUSTOMER'S
NEEDS.
THE COMMISSION WILL STILL HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY AN OPTION TO
EXTEND THE DEADLINE.
JUST AS THEY DO NOW IF
INTRACTABLE ISSUES EMERGE BUT AT
LEAST THAT EXTENSION WILL BE TEN
MONTHS SOONER THAN IT IS NOW.
ADDITIONALLY CONSOLIDATION
APPLICATION TEMPLATE CAN BE
DEVELOPED FOR ALL UTILITIES SEE
USE THAT WOULD INCORPORATE
RESPONSES TO A STANDARD SET OF
DATA REQUESTS.
CONSOLIDATIONS DRAGGING ON
BEYOND EIGHTEEN MONTHS ARE
UNACCEPTABLE IN THE CURRENT
WATER WORLD.
WHERE THE STATE HAS AN
AGGRESSIVE CONSOLIDATION POLICY?
WERE WATER SYSTEMS AND
DISADVANTAGED AND SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE IN
CHRONIC NON COMPLIANCE OR JUST
REPAIR.
AND WE'RE CUSTOMERS ARE HAVING
TO PAY FOR SUB STANDARD DRINKING
WATER UTILITY SERVICE. FOR THESE
REASONS CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION URGES AN AYE VOTE ON
AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU BOB.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER COMPUTER THOUGH ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
WATER COMPANY IN SUPPORT ALSO
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR THE CITY
OF PARIS AND THE CITY OF
BELLFLOWER.
MORE IN COMMON THE ATMOSPHERE
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
RIGHT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
OF MR HOLDEN AS CHAIR OF THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
AND AS A MEMBER OF THAT
COMMITTEE.
WE ALL KNOW.
HOW?
STRESSED.
THE P. YOU SEE IS IN TERMS OF
ITS OBLIGATIONS PURCHASES
RESOURCES.
ARM.
DO YOU WISH TO MAKE ANY COMMENT.
YOU KNOW I AM SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL -- I JUST GOT BACK IN THE
ROOM SO IF I MISSED SOMETHING IN
THE YOUR PRESENTATION -- BUT I
WOULD CONCUR THAT THE PC IS
FINDING ITSELF -- AT A PLACE
WHERE.
ARE WE ARE.
LOOKING AT WAYS TO THEIR
MODERNIZE IT'D MAKE IT MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF OF
THE COMMUNITIES IN RING ABLE TO
ADDRESS THE PRIORITY SO -- IT IS
A WORK IN PROGRESS IN TERMS OF
GETTING SOME DIRECTION FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS WELL AS
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY -- COMING
TO GRIPS WITH HOW WE CAN BETTER
ADDRESS REGULATORY SIDE OF THE
EQUATION SO.
WE ARE.
VERY HOPEFUL THE SCENES AND
THINGS HAPPEN THAT WILL MAKE A
LITTLE BIT MORE NIMBLE BUT AS WE
STAND NOW.
IT'S A VERY CHALLENGING.
THANK YOU.
A MISTER DALI.
SO I'M LOOKING AT THE THE
DEFINED DEFINITION OF A SMALL
WATER SYSTEM WHICH IS.
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM WHICH IS
TWENTY FIVE OR FEWER CONNECTIONS
SERVING OVER SIXTY DAYS SO.
I GUESS MY QUESTION IS IS.
I I COMMENDED FOR BRING THIS
BEFORE I THINK THERE'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY IN MANY AREAS.
TO COMBINED DRIVE THE COST DOWN
MAYBE GIVE A BETTER SERVICE AND
ACTUALLY CLEAN UP WATER -- BUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL
EXACTLY HOW WHOSE GET SO THE PC
IS GOING TO FORCE THEM.
TO COME CAN CONSOLIDATE.
NO THIS IS NOT AT ALL ABOUT
FORCING ANYONE TO CONSOLIDATE
THAT THE SCENARIO WE'RE
DISCUSSING IS WHEN YOU'VE GOT
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS THAT ARE
FAILING.
AND THEY WANT TO COMBINE WITH
TYPICALLY A LARGER SYSTEM OR
ANOTHER SMALL SYSTEM TO PROVIDE
DRINKING WATER TO RESIDENTS AND
SO THEY APPLY FOR APPLICATION.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
IS THE TIME FRAMES FOR THE
APPROVALS TO HAPPEN STRETCH
PRETTY DRAMATICALLY AS WERE
TRYING TO SHORTEN THAT ONE THING
I DO WANT TO SAY THAT TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR.
THE TICKET TO THE CHAIR OF YOU
AND SEE INTO THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE -- WE ARE PROPOSING A
FLEXIBLE DEADLINE AND USUALLY
THOSE TWO WORDS DON'T GO
TOGETHER BUT OUR STRONG HOPE IS
THAT -- FOR THE APPROVAL OR
DENIAL APPLICATIONS AT THAT
TAKES EIGHT MONTHS FOR THE
APPROVAL OR DENIAL OF AN ADVICE
CENTER THE TEXT FOR MONTHS.
BUT IF THOSE TIME FRAMES DON'T
WORK THE P. C.'S JUDICIAL
PROCESS DOES ALLOW FOR TIME
EXTENSIONS.
ARE AND IT ALLOWS OF THE PC
NEEDS MORE TIME TO PROCESS THE
REQUEST ADDITIONAL TIME CAN BE
GRANTED SO IT'S NOT A HARD AND
FAST RULE AND I THINK OF A REP
TO THE SMALL WATER UTILITIES
THEY WOULD WANT A HARD DEADLINE
AND WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO DO.
IS REALLY BALANCE -- WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND TO BE THE REALITY OF
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WITH THE
NEED TO REALLY MOVE THIS FOR
WHILE FOLKS ARE NOT -- ARE NOT
DON'T HAVE AVAILABLE DRINKING
WATER SO WE TRY TO BALANCE IT
BUT YOUR POINT OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCE REALLY COMES IN ONE
SMALL UTILITIES UNDERSTAND LIKE
THIS IS WHAT'S HAPPENING WE NEED
TO CONSULT.
RIGHT TO THE I GUESS MY QUESTION
YEAH BY THE WAY THIS BILL
DOESN'T REALLY.
CHANGE THE CONSOLIDATION AT ALL
IT'S TELLING THE P. YOU SEE.
OUR TO HURRY UP BUT IT'S NOT
CHANGING THE METHOD AT ALL THAT
I HAVE THAT RIGHT.
OKAY THEY'RE BOTH WANTING IT TO
HAPPEN BUT THE P. YOU SEE IS NOT
GETTING IT DONE IN A TIMELY
FASHION IS WHAT YOU'RE TELLING
ME THAT'S RIGHT [inaudible]
YEP.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
NO.
ALL RIGHT -- SEE WE HAVE A
MOTION YET NOW ALL RIGHT A
MOTION.
CURRENT FIRST BY HOLDEN SECOND
BY -- MISSED CRISTINA GARCIA.
ALL RIGHT -- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE CHIU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES
AND ENERGY QUIRK HI QUIRK AYE
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
KALRA.
COLOR AYE.
BAUER-KAHAN.
DELHI.
DELHI I CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING WHAT IT TOO
CHEAP.
PRIVATE. FIVE VOTES YOU'RE OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A COUPLE [inaudible]
MR HOLDEN
.
ALL RIGHT SO IF MR BLOOM COULD
TO JOIN US I WOULD LIKE TO DO
HIS BILL NEXT FOLLOWED BY MISTER
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
MR HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES THE STORMWATER
PERMIT COMPLIANCE FUND.
WITHIN THE STATE TREASURY.
THIS BILL ALSO INCREASES THE
CALIFORNIA FOX TIRE FEE BY A
DOLLAR FIFTY TO RAISE.
REVENUE TO FUND PROJECTS AND
PROGRAMS FOR MUNICIPAL SEPARATE
STORM SEWER SYSTEM PERMIT
COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS.
AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOR THE TIRE FEE WILL
DROP FROM THREE DOLLARS AND
TWENTY FIVE CENTS PER TIRE TO
TWO DOLLARS AND TWENTY FIVE
CENTS.
THE COMPETITIVE GRANT OFFERED BY
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD WOULD GO TOWARDS
LIMITING ZINC POLLUTANTS IN
WATER.
WHICH ARE CAUSED BY TIRE WEAR
AND OTHER SOURCES.
I PLAN ON CONTINUING TO WORK ON
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS WITH THE
WATER BOARD'S CAL RECYCLE IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX.
AND FEE THAT CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERS THE TIRE BE POOR CAL
RECYCLE AND A. R. B..
STORM WATER RUNOFF AND POLLUTION
ARE COMMON CAUSES OF THE HIGH
COSTS OF WATER INFRASTRUCTURE AS
SOPHISTICATED SYSTEMS ARE
REQUIRED TO TEST FOR AND TREAT
POLLUTANTS.
I RECOGNIZE THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION AND WEIGH THEM WITH
THE REALITIES CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CONFRONTED WITH.
I LOOK FORWARD TO EXPLORING WAYS
WE CAN MAKE THIS APPROACH BIBLE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IN ORDER TO COMPLY WITH THE M.
S. FOR PERMITS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE TO INVEST BILLIONS AND
WATERSHED INFRASTRUCTURE AND
STORM WATER CAPTURE.
TECHNOLOGY TO MAINTAIN A HEALTHY
QUALITY OF WATER BILLIONS THEY
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE.
THIS BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE TO ADDRESS
STORM WATER FUNDING FOR LA
COUNTY AND MAKES GRANTS
AVAILABLE TO MISS APOLOGIES
ACROSS THE STATE. FOR THESE
REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY IS PAUL HITLER
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AND
COMMUNITY RELATIONS FOR THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M PAUL HUBER TODAY
REPRESENTING THE THIRTY CITIES
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS.
AS THE SPONSOR OF AB SEVEN FIVE
FIVE AS ASSEMBLYMAN HOLDEN AS
STATED A. B. SEVEN FIVE FIVE
WOULD INCREASE THE CALIFORNIA
TIRE FEE.
BY MODEST DOLLAR FIFTY PER TIRE
OR ABOUT A DOLLAR FIFTY PER YEAR
FOR THE AVERAGE MOTORIST. TO
HELP CITIES FUND CLEANUP
PROJECTS TO REDUCE AND ELIMINATE
ZINC.
ISN'T FOUND IN STORM WATER
RUNOFF TIRE WEAR IS A MAJOR
SOURCE OF ZINC AND URBAN RUNOFF
RESPONSIBLE 440% 280% OF ZINC.
IN ROAD SOURCE RUNOFF ACCORDING
TO TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT NEW
ZEALAND STUDY.
ZINC IS AMONG SEVERAL DOZEN
HEAVY METALS AND OTHER
CONTAMINANTS THAT ARE CONSIDERED
HIGH LEVEL WATER QUALITY THREATS
FOR IMPAIRED WATER BODIES IN THE
LOS ANGELES REGION.
AND THROUGHOUT LARGE AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA.
ELEVATED ZINC CONCENTRATIONS IN
URBAN RUNOFF MUST BE ADDRESSED
TO ACHIEVE CLEAN WATER ACT
COMPLIANCE IN MANY CALIFORNIA
URBAN AREAS.
THE REMOVAL OF CONTAMINANTS
INCLUDING SING FROM STORM WATER
IS AN URGENT ISSUE AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN HAS MENTIONED. FOR
EXAMPLE.
REMEDIATING SINK IT WILL COST AN
ESTIMATED TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE.
AND IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE
I HILL FROM EIGHT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IS THE COST ESTIMATE.
AB SEVEN FIVE FIVE OFFERS A MUCH
NEEDED FUNDING TOOL TO OFFSET
THE COSTS OF REDUCING FOR
MEDIATION WHILE THE INDUSTRY AND
REGULATORS WORK TOWARD THE
LONGER TERM GOAL OF REMOVING.
OR REDUCING SINKING TIRES THERE
ARE THIRTY MILLION TIRES SOLD
ANNUALLY IN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT THE PERMIT
COMPLIANCE FUND.
ESTABLISHED UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD RAISE
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY WHICH WOULD BE
INVESTED IN THE STATE'S
COMMUNITIES TO REDUCE AND
ELIMINATE SINK IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS URGES YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN FIVE FIVE TO HELP
OUR COMMUNITIES IMPROVE THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WARREN COLEMAN BRP SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
AND IF YOU HAVE AN ON ON BEHALF
OF HEAL THE BAY AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A COULD I HAVE THE OPPOSITION
COME UP TO THE TABLE.
THE AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAY JEFF
SAVERS ON BEHALF OF THE U. S.
TIRE MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION.
HOW WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AND -- CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS THE OFFICE STAFF AND
BUT FOR THE SIMPLE FACT THAT
THIS BILL NEARLY DOUBLES THE
TIRE TAX CHARGE ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT'S
PRIMARILY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK WE DO TAKE A LITTLE BIT
OF ISSUE WHERE THE THAT
PROPONENTS ARE SAYING THAT.
THE THE ZINC IN THE STORM WATERS
L..
DRAMATICALLY -- PRIMARILY CAUSED
BY BY TIRES.
THEY COME FROM A LOT OF SOURCES
NATURALLY OCCURRING IN A LOT OF
COATINGS ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THAT HAVE THAT GALVANIZED METAL
ESPECIALLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
IF IT WAS AS BIG OF A DEAL WITH
TIRES AS THEY SAY THE WHITE IS
THE BAY AREA HAVE ANY ISSUES
WITH THINK OF THEIR SOMEONE
RUNOFF.
CELL.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS TO BE
STUDY CARRY CYCLES CURRENTLY
STUDYING THIS -- AND AND
IDENTIFYING SEVERAL SITES WERE
ACTUALLY TESTING THIS YEAR THE
CITY IS THIS ACTUALLY AN ISSUE.
THAT SAID -- WE THINK THERE ARE
THERE ARE ISSUES THAT THE
COUNTIES ARE ARE ARE DEALING
WITH A GRAPPLING WITH THE M. S.
FOR PERMITTING STRUCTURE IS IS
OF CONCERN.
YEAH ELLE -- THERE ARE DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS THAT ARE
THREATENING LAWSUITS AND I
UNDERSTAND THEY ARE LOOKING FOR
A WAY -- WE PROPOSE A POTENTIAL
ALTERNATIVE THAT WE LIKE
CONTINUE TO EXPLORING WITH THEM --
BUT UNTIL WE GET TO THAT.
WE ARE STILL THIS POSITION OF
OPPOSE.
I AM I ALSO LIKE TO SAY CAL
RECYCLES LOOKING AT TIRES
ACTUALLY AS A WAY OF CLEANING UP
THIS STORM WATER SYSTEM THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE FUNDED A COUPLE OF
PROJECTS WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
USING GROUND TIRES.
ALMOST LIKE A SPONGE BEFORE THE
WATER GETS IN THE FORMER SYSTEM
WHICH TREMENDOUS RESULTS.
SELL -- THEY'RE ACTUALLY
FIGHTING BETTER RESULTS WITH
THAT KEEP WORKING WITH CAL
RECYCLE TO HELP FIND A SOLUTION
TO THIS.
AND I KNOW MY TIME IS UP PLEASE
READ RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR NO
VOTE [inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON JACK MULLIN
DONOVAN BEHALF OF THE AUTOMOTIVE
SERVICE COUNCILS OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA AUTOMOTIVE BUSINESS
COALITION AND THE CALIFORNIA
TIRE DEALERS ASSOCIATION THE
DOLLAR FIFTY TAX IS A REGRESSIVE
TAX AND IT FALLS HARDEST.
ON LOW INCOME AND WE'RE HARD
HARD WORKING FAMILIES -- TIRE
DEALERS HAVE COUNTLESS STORIES
WERE POTENTIAL CUP CUSTOMERS
DELAY THE PURCHASE OF TIRES
BECAUSE OF THE COST AND THEY
SIMPLY.
DRIVE AWAY WITH DANGEROUS BALD
TIRES BECAUSE OF THE COST OF THE
TIRE IT'S NOT ONLY THE TIRE BUT
THEIR SALES TAX THERE'S ALSO
DISPOSAL FEE.
THERE IS A CURRENT FEE OF A
DOLLAR SEVENTY FIVE AND NOW THIS
ISN'T GOING TO BE AN ADDITIONAL
DOLLAR FIFTY PER TIRE.
WE RECOGNIZE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT BECAUSE BY THE THE
POLLUTANTS THAT ENTERED THE
STORM WATER RUNOFF -- BUT WHY
ARE WE PICKING ON TIRES ZINC IS
IN MANY CONSUMER PRODUCTS AS WAS
MENTIONED THERE AN OUTDOOR METAL
SURFACES GALVANIZED STEEL.
OF WHICH IS COATED WITH LIQUID
ZINC.
OF EIGHT TO PET FOR CORROSION
PROTECTION OF SUCH AS LIGHTS
SIGNS BENCHES ROOFS.
OF THEY ALL CONTRIBUTE TO THE
STORM RUNOFF -- WE BELIEVE THAT
ANY NEW FEES SHOULD BE SHARED
FAIRLY AMONG ALL PRODUCTS THAT
CAUSE POLLUTANTS TO ENTER THE
THE THE STREAM WATER RUN OFF NOT
JUST.
PICKING ON TIRES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A THORN CAL CHAMBER FOR
THE REASONS OUTLINED BY COLLEGE
ALSO COLLEAGUES ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
MISS SARAH OUR QUE HAN.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
OF SINISTER HOLDEN I'M A COUPLE
QUESTIONS AND ONE WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION ICE I NOTICED IN THE
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ALTHOUGH
HE'LL THE BAY WAS HERE TODAY --
AND THAT'S NEW TO ME MOST OF THE
SPORT IS COMING FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHICH MAKES ME THINK
THAT MOST OF THE IMPACT AND FEES
ARE BEING SPENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DO YOU HAVE DATA ON
WHERE.
THE FEES ARE BEING USED AND HOW.
WELL MAYBE YOU HAVE SOME
SPECIFICS BUT I KNOW THAT --
WHERE IT'S A BIGGER ISSUE FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO BE SURE
BECAUSE OF THE RESPONSIBILITY
UNDER THE SAME AS FOR PERMITS TO
THEN COME UP WITH PROJECTS THAT
ARE GOING TO LOOK? FOR A STORM
WATER ARE RECAPTURE AND THERE
HAVE BEEN STUDIES AND REPORTS
DONE THAT DEFINITELY MAKE A A
NEXUS LINK BETWEEN TIRE.
AND ZINC COULD.
FIND ITS WAY INTO THE STORM
WATER RUNOFF IT SO IT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU HAVE THESE
POLLUTED WATERS THAT YOU'RE
DEALING WITH IT IS A PRIORITY
FOR US IT'S NOT TO SAY THAT.
BECAUSE CLEARLY IF THE STUDY
SAYING THAT ZINC IS COMING FROM
TIRES THAT IT'S GOING TO BE.
PART OF THE PROBLEM IN TERMS OF
POLLUTANTS TO BE DEALT WITH
WE'RE DEALING WITH IT
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING
TO WORK VERY AGGRESSIVELY IN OUR
AREA -- TO GENERATE REVENUE --
TO HELP ADDRESS THE PROBLEM AND
SO AS IT RELATES TO OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT IT'S NOT
AN IMPACT ISSUE IT'S JUST
BECAUSE FOR US TO TO FOCUS ON IT
MORE YEAH.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE JUST
HAVEN'T GONE THROUGH THAT
PROCESS IN THE BAY AREA IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE.
AND WHEN WE DO WE'LL PROBABLY
FIND WE HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM.
ON THE I'M NOT ALSO JUST ADD
WELL TIRES YOU'RE NOT.
THE ONLY ITEM CAUSING SINK
POLLUTION.
THEY'RE NOT TAXING IT AT A RATE.
THAT WOULD PAY THE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS THAT IT'S GONNA COST
FOR THE CLEANUP -- AT IT'S A
SMALL DROP IN THE BUCKET.
BEN AND I JUST I GUESS I WOULD
ALSO HI IN RESPONSE TO THE
COMMENT WHERE.
THE UP.
POOR FAMILIES WERE OR DRIVING
AWAY FROM ON WITH BALL TIRES
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF TIRES AND
SO THEREFORE THEY'RE NOT.
BUYING TIRES.
I I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU THAT THE
COSTS OF THE TIRES ARE EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE THEY ARE BEING PRICE
THAT.
THAT THIS FEE IS AS HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT AS A VERY NOMINAL
FEE.
AS IT RELATES TO TRY BECAUSE
THERE'S AN IMPACT THAT THE TIRES
HAVING ON OUR STORM WATER RUNOFF
AND SO WE'RE ADDRESSING IT FROM
THAT STANDPOINT BUT HI AND I I
GO OUT TO LOOK AT THE CAR.
THE THE COSTA TURNS INTO THE
FEES THESE FEES ARE NOT WHAT'S
MAKING THEM -- EXCESSIVELY
EXPENSIVE.
YES.
MS GARCIA ARE YOU HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL KOSHER GO AHEAD.
AND THEN MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE EXISTING LAW SUNSETS IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR DO I HAVE
THAT RIGHT.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SO WHY IT CAN YOU JUST HELP ME
UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE DOING THIS
NOW AND WE'RE NOT WAITING UNTIL
THE SUN SET AND THEN JUST --
CLOSER TO THE SUNSET DISCUSSING
IT IS IT JUST SO WE CAN RAISE
THE FEES SIR.
THE LOGIC THERE -- AS THE CHAIRS
POINTED OUT THIS IS REALLY A A
DROP IN THE BUCKET NO PUN
INTENDED BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THAT.
THE THE COST OF THE PROJECT ARK
EXCESSIVE AND WE DID PASS A
MEASURE SO THAT -- LA COUNTY
VOTERS HAVE A OPPOSED A ATTACKS
ON THEMSELVES TO GENERATE MORE
MONEY FOR THESE PROJECTS FOR
THESE LIMITS FOR PROJECTS.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE TOOLS ARE
JUST SEEN AS A TOOL IN OUR A
TOOL.
BOX TO HELP US CONTINUE TO GET
OUR WAY TO WHERE I THINK WE CAN
HAVE AT LEAST.
SOME RESOURCE TO HELP RELIEVE
SOME OF THE SMALLER CITIES SOME
WITH POPULATIONS OF UNDER TWENTY
THOUSAND AND EXPOSURE -- TO
PROJECTS IN RESPONSIBILITY FOR
PROJECTS -- IN EXCESS OF A
HUNDRED MILLION SO WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND AS MANY DIFFERENT
APPROACHES THAT WILL HELP
RELIEVE THE THE IMPACT ON OF THE
CONSUMER AND THE THE TAXPAYER IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
I AM GOING TO HAVE TO GO TO
PUBLIC SAFETY TO VOTE.
AB YES AND YOU PROBABLY DO --
TOO I WILL LEAVE THE BUT WE WILL
BUT FIRST I HAVE TO GET SOMEBODY
CHAIRED THE MEETING WHILE I'M
GONE.
I MISS GARCIA WOULD YOU BE
WILLING.
ALL RIGHT.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE TIMER.
AND V. E. R. [inaudible]
RESEARCHER -- WITH -- YOUR
INDULGENCES THERE.
ARE POSSIBLY TO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND BEFORE YOU.
THANK YOU YOU CAN TELL YOUR
COMMITTEE CHAIRS I SECOND THE
MOTION.
CHAIRMAN PARK MY OF MY QUESTIONS
MORE FOR YOU BEING THAT I DON'T
COME FROM A SCIENTIFIC
BACKGROUND WE WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE SAME ZINC THAT IS
PRESCRIBED AND SUPPLEMENTS FOR
PREGNANT WOMEN.
THAT'S WHAT.
ZINC IS ALSO PRESCRIBED AS A
SUPPLEMENT IS IS THE SAME --
YANK SAME THING.
IT'S PROBABLY ZINC COMPOUND AS
OPPOSED TO PURE SAYING THAT IT'S
THE SAME MATERIAL.
HELLO HI THIS A SUPPLEMENT IS
PROBABLY A COMPOUND.
RATHER THAN PIERCING.
BUT I TAKE IT.
ALL RIGHT SO SO WE WANT TO TAX
THE CHEMICAL.
THE CHEMICAL COMPOSITION MAKES A
HUGE DIFFERENCE PRINTERS INK IS
GOING.
TO REACT IN A WAY THAT IS IN
COMPOUND DOES NOT [inaudible]
THANK.
WE HAVE OUR VICE CHAIR
[inaudible]
YEAH -- WILL WILL GIVE YOU THE
I'VE GOT TO GO DOWN IN VOTING
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE LAST YEAR.
THERE'S NOT NECESSARILY.
ITEM FIVE MOTION AND A SECOND --
I'M SORRY MISS GARCIA.
THANK YOU -- THIS WHOLE IN ANY
BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR
MULTIPLE YEARS NOW AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR DEDICATION I'M
GONNA VOTE FOR THIS.
BILL AGAIN AND I'M NOT GOING TO
ASK YOU A QUESTION TO MAKE THE
COMMENT THAT I'VE MADE
PREVIOUSLY AND HOPEFULLY BEFORE
THIS COMES.
ME ON THE FLOOR WILL HAVE AN
ANSWER BUT ABOUT THE QUESTION
ABOUT A FEE THAT IS SHARED BOTH
BY THE CONSUMERS AND THE
MANUFACTURE SENATE NOT THIS
PUNISHES THE CONSUMERS.
AND I HOPE THAT BEFORE I SEE
THIS AGAIN THERE'S SOME SORT OF
CONCLUSION IN THAT DIRECTION AND
I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS.
ONE OF MANY TOOLS THAT WE NEED
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM IN THIS IS
NOT GOING TO SOLVE ALLOUR
PROBLEMS.
ALONG THE WAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS GARCIA -- MR HOLDEN
DID YOU MAKE YOUR CLOTHES OR NOW.
YES YOU DID OKAY I I'D LIKE IT
OKAY AND CONSIDER MY LAST
COMMENT TO BE MY CLOTHES OKAY
WERE YOU HERE WELCOME TO MAKE A
LINK THERE ONE IF YOU'D LIKE
WELL I I I WILL SAY THAT -- TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA IS A
QUESTION WE'RE MANUFACTURER TAX
COULD ALSO MIGHT ALSO BE LOOKED
AT THE THE CHALLENGE WITH THAT
IS THAT THERE'S THAT THAT WOULD
BE.
CONSIDERED MORE OF A HIDDEN TAX.
AND THE TIRE FEE TAXES ONE THAT
IS.
A VERY CLEAR FOR THE CONSUMER TO
SEE AN AND NO -- WHAT?
IS BEING THE THE TAXES BEING
USED FOR THE FEE IS BEING USED
FOR AND HOW IT WOULD BE APPLIED.
WHERE'S THE MANUFACTURERS
ACCORDING TO THE PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY FEE.
WOULD BE MORE OF A HIDDEN TAX OR
HIDDEN FEE.
SO IT'S REALLY MORE OF
TRANSPARENT.
WAY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE BUT IT
IS A POSSIBLE.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT -- WITH THAT THERE IS A
MOTION AND A SECOND SO WITH THE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE HOLDEN THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AND REFERRED
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN.
DELHI.
DELHI NO.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA I HOLDEN.
AYE HOLDEN AYE.
MATHIS NO MATHIS KNOW.
WHAT A TO G.?
OKAY SO WILL HOLD IT UP.
OKAY THAT BILL IS ON IS ON CALL.
OKAY WE DON'T HAVE ANY MORE BILL
AUTHORS YET DO WE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLAND -- HAVE A SURGEON COSTS
CALLED ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOMS
OFFICE YES HE ON HIS WAY -- HE
IS.
YEAH -- OKAY.
PLEASE ENJOY THE MUSIC WHILE WE
WAIT ON
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
WE'RE NOT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
ALL.
ON ONE BILL SURE OKAY.
I'M GONNA OPEN THE ROLE WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE ROLE ON JUST ITEM
NUMBER -- FIFTEEN FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS TO CHANGES VOTE
FROM NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
I SEVEN ZERO SO THEN THAT BILL
IS OUT RIGHT -- WAS OUT BEFORE I
GUESS [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA DO YOU ADD
ONS NOW WHILE WE WAIT FOR THE
BILL AUTHORS TO COME AND PRESENT
SECTOR.
SIR WITH ITEM.
ONE I'M SORRY IN TWO YEAH.
WE'RE DOING AT ARMS NOW ON ITEM
NUMBER.
TWO IT'S AB FIVE OH EIGHT CHIU --
THE VOTE IS AT FIVE TWO
CURRENTLY MELENDEZ SNOW MELENDEZ
NO.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA HI SO THAT TAKES
THE VOTE. TWO SIX THREE THE BILL
IS OUT IN THE BILL IS OUT.
OKAY THE NEXT BILL IS ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB SIX THIRTY SEVEN
GREAT.
ARE THE VOTE COUNT STANDS AT
SEVEN ZERO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
SO TAKE THE VOTE.
NINE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SIX
FORTY SEVEN FOR ADD ONS -- TO
VOTE STANDS AT FOUR ZERO
MELENDEZ -- THAT'S OKAY.
I THINK I'M GONNA NOT VOTING.
SOMEONE IS NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
BY BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I AND MURATSUCHI
IS NOT HERE.
SO THAT BRINGS THE VOTE ON THAT
BILL TWO FIVE ZERO SO THAT ONE
PASSES OUT OF COMMITTEE.
WE'LL KEEP THAT WOULD OPEN AS
WELL -- FOR ADD ONS.
WE JUST.
EIGHTY FIVE NUMBER WHICH IS WHAT
ABOUT [inaudible]
FIVE NO.
YEAH I'M GONNA GO IN ORDER
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO THE NEXT BILL IS ITEM TEN AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO FOR ADD ONS.
THE VOTE STANDS AT SIX ZERO
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ I DALLY.
THIS IS A. B. FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO
SANTIAGO.
DALY AYE.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I SO THAT BRINGS THE VOTE.
TWO NINE ZERO THE NEXT BILL FOR
ADAMS IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
FIFTEEN OH NINE MULLIN.
THE VOTE IS AT FOUR ZERO
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING BY
BAUER-KAHAN CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA AYE.
THAT TAKES THE VOTE TO FIVE ZERO
THAT ONE PASSES OUT WILL STAY
OPEN FOR ON THE OTHER MEMBER
[inaudible]
SEE [inaudible] FIFTEEN OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN FOR ADD ONS
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE JUNE.
THE VOTE IS AT SEVEN ZERO LET'S
SEE.
OUR CAN WE JUST ABOUT OKAY SO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS THAT.
BRAD ONS CONSENT.
THE VOTE IS AT SIX MELENDEZ.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR I DALY
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR DALY AYE.
AND HOLDEN ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HI.
A CRISTINA I'M SORRY CRISTINA
GARCIA.
HI SORRY THAT'S NINE OKAY SOUNDS
COMPLETE [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
HELLO
.
I MEAN THAT THE YEAH
[inaudible]
AND YEAH.
THE MAN WILL TAKE [inaudible]
ANOTHER REGULAR.
THE FIRST FLOOR.
I KNOW.
THERE.
IT WAS NOT.
NUMBER FIVE AND EXPECTED NO IT
LOOKS LIKE [inaudible]
IT'S I THINK.
BUT IN REALITY [inaudible]
THE THE MORNING EMAIL
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE LAST THING ON YEAH
[inaudible]
YEAH.
YEAH YEAH.
YEAH [inaudible]
BETTER [inaudible]
YEAH.
NOTHING.
NO INTERNET BREAKING
.
EMILY TRAIN FIX
I'M OPENING UP WE'RE OPENING UP
THE ROLE TO DO ADD ON'S AND IF
YOU BILLS.
IT'S ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SIX
FORTY SEVEN KALRA.
THE VOTE STANDS NOW AT FIVE ZERO
BAUER-KAHAN ON A. B. SIX FORTY
SEVEN KALRA HI.
I MODES TO CHEAT.
MURATSUCHI HI [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible] SEVEN ZERO ALL
RIGHT.
MISTER MURATSUCHI WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT AND WHICH BILL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT ON FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO START WITH THE AB
[inaudible]
FOUR NINE FIVE VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
CHAIR -- FOR WORKING WITH ME AND
THANK YOU TO YOUR STAFF FOR
THEIR EXCELLENT -- IN DEPTH
ANALYSIS OF OF THIS BILL AND THE
ISSUES PRESENTED BY THIS BILL.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
ARE PRESENTING THIS BILL --
TODAY FOR INFORMATIONAL.
PURPOSES BUT THAT WE WILL NOT BE
TAKEN A HEARING -- I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. TO KEEP AN OPEN MIND ON
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS A A LANDMARK A BILL
AND AND WITH THE NATIONAL
CONSEQUENCES AND SO -- WE ASK
THAT -- WE WE APPRECIATE A A
THOUGHTFUL.
FEDERATION OF THE ISSUES THAT
ARE BEING PRESENTED BY A. B.
FOUR NINE FIVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
FOR I HAD CERTAINLY A NUMBER OF
MY MEMBERS WHO JUST FELT THEY
NEEDED MORE INFORMATION.
SO WILL ACCEPT YOUR TESTIMONY
AND PUT THE VOTE OVER FOR LATER
DAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
END UP BECAUSE THIS IS A HIGHLY
TECHNICAL ISSUE.
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW INSTEAD OF
FOUR MINUTES PER SIDE EIGHT
MINUTES PER SIDE SO -- I SEE
HAVE LOTS OF WITNESSES THAT
SHOULD MAKE THINGS A LITTLE
EASIER THANK YOU THANK YOU SO I
ALONG WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BUFFY WICKS THE JOINT AUTHORED
THIS BILL IS PRESENTING.
THE TOXIC FREE KEMET COSMETICS
ACT.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO PROTECT
CHILDREN WOMEN AND MEN FROM
COSMETIC PRODUCTS THAT CONTAIN
HIGHLY TOXIC CHEMICALS.
THIS BILL PROPOSES A BAN ON THE
SALE OF COSMETICS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT CONTAIN
TWENTY HIGHLY TOXIC CHEMICALS
KNOWN TO CAUSE.
CANCER REPRODUCTIVE HARM OR
HEART HORMONE DISRUPTION.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PRODUCTS
THAT WE APPLY ON OUR BODIES ON A
DAILY BASIS.
FACIAL POWDER CONTAMINATED WITH
THIS BEST THIS LIPSTICK
CONTAINING LEAD.
BABY SHAMPOO WITH FORMALDEHYDE
AND OTHERS.
THE STATUS QUO IS NOT PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
BIG GREEN CHEMISTRY -- PROGRAM A
WE HAVE HAD A HEARING IN THIS
COMMITTEE ARE.
AND AND THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THE THE EXCELLENT COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS LAYS OUT WHY THE GREEN
KEVIN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM HAS
PROVEN TO BE AN ADEQUATE.
IN A PROPOSED AND IN ADDRESSING.
THESE ISSUES AND IN PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND SO --
HERE TO TALK -- RATHER THAN MY
DOING MORE TALKING I WOULD LIKE
TO TURN OVER WE HAVE A THE
PRIVILEGE OF HAVING SEVERAL --
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES FOR MANY YEARS AS
WELL AS AN EXPERT ON THE IMPACT
OF TOXIC CHEMICALS ESPECIALLY ON
LOW INCOME AND LOW INCOME WOMEN
OF COLOR.
OUTSIDE LIKE TO TURN OVER -- TO
FIRST TO SCOTT FABER -- THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP THEN --
EMILY RUSS -- WITH CALPERS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
CALPERS OUR SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL -- AND FOLLOWING THEM I'D
LIKE TO ASK DOCTOR ARMIES SO TO
THE PROFESSOR AT GEORGE
WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH -- TO TESTIFY ON
HER RESEARCH AND LAST BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LEAST FROM MOLLY
JENSEN -- FROM THE COSMETICS
MANUFACTURING COMPANY -- NAMED
BY WILSON'S SO HARD TO YES YOU
DIDN'T MEAN TO SAY THAT CURRENT
PRACTICE OF OF A COMPANIES JUST
PUT LEAD OR ASBESTOS IN THEIR
PRODUCT.
YOU YOU WERE SAYING THAT WERE
YOU I AM SAYING THAT SAID THERE
ARE THERE HAVE BEEN.
A COSMETICS WITH THOSE CHEMICALS
FOUND -- YEAH BUT THAT'S NOT
CURRENT PRACTICE TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
WE WE WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
PRODUCTS BEING SOLD ON ON
SHELVES -- YOU DIDN'T DO NOT
CONTAIN THOSE TOXIC CHEMICAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO FIRST I'D LIKE TO TURN OFF
OVER TO SCOTT FABER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I GET MY NAME AGAIN IS
SCOTT FABER I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP.
AND I'M ALSO AN ADJUNCT
PROFESSOR AT GEORGETOWN
UNIVERSITY LAW CENTER.
LET ME START BY SAYING NO
CATEGORY OF CONSUMER PRODUCTS.
IS SUBJECT TO LAST OVERSIGHT
THAN COSMETICS AND OTHER
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COSMETICS
COMPANIES CONCLUDE JUST ABOUT
ANY CHEMICAL IN JUST ABOUT ANY
AMOUNT.
IN PRODUCTS WE USE IN OUR HOMES
EVERY DAY IN FACT SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND NINE COSMETICS
COMPANIES HAVE REPORTED USING
EIGHTY EIGHT CHEMICALS LINKED TO
CANCER BIRTH DEFECTS OR
REPRODUCTIVE HARM.
IN PRODUCTS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WHILE MORE THAN FORTY
COUNTRIES HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO
BAN OR RESTRICT MORE THAN ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED CHEMICALS
AND CONTAMINANTS AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS.
ARE FTA HAS SO FAR ONLY BANNED
OR RESTRICTED NINE CHEMICALS OR
CONTAMINANTS FOR SAFETY REASONS --
IT'S BEEN MORE THAN EIGHTY YEARS
SINCE CONGRESS LAST ACTED TO
ENACT COSMETICS LEGISLATION AND
SINCE THEN.
CONGRESS HAS GIVEN THE FDA AND
THE EPA THE POWER TO REVIEW AND
REGULATE CHEMICALS IN FOOD AND
COLORS AND PESTICIDES IN OVER
THE COUNTER DRUGS IN CLEANING
PRODUCTS.
BUT CONGRESS HAS NOT GIVEN THE
FDA THE POWER THE SAME POWERS TO
RESTRICT DANGEROUS CHEMICALS OR
CONTAMINANTS AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS.
WE THINK THAT CUT CONSUMER
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WAIT ANOTHER
EIGHTY YEARS FOR CONGRESS TO ACT
AND THAT'S WHY WE THINK
CALIFORNIA.
SHOULD JOIN MORE THAN FORTY
NATIONS AND MANY OF OUR NATION'S
BIGGEST RETAILERS.
AND FINALLY BANNED THE WORST OF
THE WORST CHEMICALS IN THESE
EVERYDAY PRODUCTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT.
MY NAME.
MY NAME'S EMILY RASH I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALPERS
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC INTEREST
RESEARCH GROUP.
TOM WERE ANOTHER CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL WE'VE LONG WORKED TO
HELP PRODUCE HUMAN EXPOSURE TO
TOXIC CHEMICALS.
AND AN EARLY TWO THOUSAND
COMMISSIONS SOME INDEPENDENT
LATIN ACCREDITED LABORATORY TO
DO TESTING OF THE MAKE UP THAT
WE BOUGHT AT CLEARS BOUTIQUES
THAT DEPICTED A STORE IN MALLS --
AS WELL AS SOME OTHER STORES AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOUND AS BEST AS
IN SEVERAL -- PRODUCTS
CONTAINING TALC SO I SHADOW
SPACE PATRICK CETERA.
THESE ARE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
MARKETED -- TO USUALLY TEENS
FREQUENT THAT STORE MOST
COMMONLY.
AND WE ALERT ABOUT THE FDA AND
CLEARS IMMEDIATELY UPON FINDING
THE RESULTS -- UNFORTUNATELY THE
PRODUCTS -- STAYED ON STORE
SHELVES. FOR MORE THAN A YEAR.
I'M AT THE FTA EVENTUALLY DID
THEIR OWN TEST RESULTS AND
ACTUALLY CAME OUT WITH THEIR
TEST RESULTS LAST MONTH
CONFIRMING OUR TEST RESULTS AS
BEST AS WELL AS IN THE PRODUCTS.
I'M BUT NOTED THAT THEY'D
ACTUALLY DIDN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE CLEARS TO
REMOVE THEM FROM STORE SHELVES --
CLEARS DID VOLUNTARILY REMOVE
THEM FROM STORE SHELVES A FEW
DAYS LATER UNDER PRESSURE -- BUT
IT WAS I OPENING FOR ME AT LEAST
TO REALIZE THAT WE ACTUALLY
DON'T.
YEAH IT IS UP TO THE COMPANIES
TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT TO KEEP
THOSE PRODUCTS ON STORE SHELVES
SO THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE OF WHY WE
GOT INVOLVED WITH THIS BILL -- I
DON'T THINK ANYONE I THINK
EVERYONE HERE KNOWS HOW HARMFUL
AS BEST AS CAN BE AS BEST AS CAN
BE TO HUMAN HEALTH.
I'M AND WHY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT BOTH CONTAMINANTS LIKE LEAD
AND ASBESTOS AS WELL AS SOME OF
THESE OTHER KNOWN TOXIC
CHEMICALS THAT ARE INTENTIONALLY
ADDED TO PRODUCTS -- ARE TAKEN
OUT.
I'M.
I BROUGHT WITH ME A HANDFUL OF
PRODUCTS THAT WE FOUND ON STORE
SHELVES.
ALL WITHIN FIVE TO ELEVEN
DOLLARS -- THAT WOULD MEET AB
FOR NINETY FIVE I'M AT LEAST.
AT LEAST ACCORDING TO THE
INGREDIENT LIST ON THE LABEL.
AND THE I'M SORRY OF MS ROSS IF
IF YOU CAN TALK ABOUT HOW THESE
WERE FOUND TO BE A AFFORDABLE
ALTERNATIVES TO APPS I MEAN SOME
OF THESE -- TO PRESS CONDITIONER
AND SHAMPOO WERE FOUND A GROCERY
OUTLET -- BOTH OF I THINK FOR
FIVE DOLLARS AND SIX DOLLARS.
AND THESE ARE PRODUCTS AND UNDER
THE WALGREENS FRANCE A WALGREENS
RITE AID CVS TARGET ARE AMONG
THE COP ON COMPANIES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY -- REQUIRING FOR THEIR
STORE BRAND PRODUCTS THEY'VE
ACTUALLY GONE SO FAR AS TO SAY
WE WANT TO REFORMULATE THESE
PRODUCTS.
TO ELIMINATE MANY MORE CHEMICALS
ACTUALLY THAT ARE ON OUR LIST IN
OUR BILL CITIES ARE BOTH
WALGREENS BRANDS -- LOTION AND
CLEANSER THAT WOULD MEET AB FOR
NINETY FIVE AS WRITTEN.
AND THIS IS THAT CANDID --
FOUNDATION -- ME WITHOUT
PARABENS THEM THAT WAS -- TEN
NINETY NINE MASCHERA AND WE
FOUND SEVERAL PRODUCTS FROM
REDLINE YOU KNOW AGAIN AT SUCH A
CVS AND RITE AID -- THAT -- YOU
KNOW ART DON'T USE CARBON BLACK
THAT ARE -- MEET THE STANDS OF
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FIVE CAPTION
HOUSE BECAUSE I'M WITH THE THE
MASCARA WAS EIGHT NINETY NINE
AND THE LINER WAS [inaudible]
ELEVEN NINETY NINE THANK YOU.
I HAVE TO GO PRESENTED.
THANK YOU.
THE PROFESSOR.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOCTOR ARMY
SODA AND I'M A PROFESSOR OF
ENVIRONMENTAL AND OCCUPATIONAL
HEALTH AT THE GEORGE WASHINGTON
UNIVERSITY MILKEN SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
I AM AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS AN EDUCATOR AND I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PUBLIC'S
WIDESPREAD AN INVOLUNTARY
EXPOSURES TO TOXIC CHEMICALS.
AND I'M NOT ALONE THERE IS
GROWING SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS
ABOUT THE PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS
OF TOXIC CHEMICALS.
THEY CAN LEAD TO A MYRIAD OF
HEALTH PROBLEMS EARLY IN LIFE
LATER IN LIFE OR EVEN ACROSS
GENERATIONS INDEED THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION ESTIMATES
THAT AS MUCH AS 24% OF GLOBAL
DISEASE.
IS CAUSED BY ENVIRONMENTAL
EXPOSURES
THAT CAN BE AVERTED I
WANT TO NOW TALK INDEFINITELY
ABOUT A FEW OF THE CHEMICALS
THAT ARE -- PART OF THIS BILL
AND WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH THE FAX FOR EXAMPLE
LASTLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
OTHER VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF COLOR FROM
MINORITY POPULATIONS BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN HIGHER EXPOSURES TO
BEAUTY PRODUCT RELATED CHEMICALS
WE'VE ALSO FOUND THAT THESE
EXPOSURES CAN BE LINKED TO SOME
OF THE STARK HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND MANY MEMBERS OF MINORITY
GROUPS -- ALSO WORK IN.
OCCUPATIONAL ENVIRONMENTS SUCH
AS HAIR SALONS AND NARAL NAIL
SALONS WHERE THEY CAN ALSO BE
EXPOSED -- TO SOME OF THESE
TOXIC AGENT SO I'LL AND THERE
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT YOU HAVE THIRTY
SECONDS.
WILL GO QUICKLY.
MY NAME IS MOLLY JENSEN I WORK
FOR A COMPANY CALLED BIOSCIENCE
WHICH IS THE IT'S A OWNED BY A
PARENT COMPANY AMOROUS WHICH HAS
ABOUT.
FOUR HUNDRED EMPLOYEES I'VE BEEN
IN THE BEAUTY INDUSTRY FOR
THIRTY FIVE PLUS YEARS AND HAVE
SEEN A LOT OF CHANGES -- I CAN
ATTEST TO THE FACT THAT THESE
CHEMICALS ARE NOT NEEDED I'M A
FORMULATOR AS WELL.
AND BASICALLY THAT THEY'RE VERY
ANTIQUATED AND IT'S IT'S NOT
SOMETHING ABOUT.
I'M NOT HERE ON BEHALF OF MY CUT
MY CUSTOMER BECAUSE MY CUSTOMER
OF IS ALREADY OF OF SEARCHING
FOR CLEANING PRODUCTS.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL THAT GOES
INTO A WALGREENS LOOKING FOR THE
THE BLOCKS OF LIP GLOSS OR EYE
SHADOW.
THAT DOESN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
INGREDIENTS AND DOESN'T HAVE THE
SAFEGUARD.
SO I THINK IT REALLY IS VITAL
FOR THE CONSUMER TO KNOW THAT
THEY CAN GO IN AND BUY PRODUCTS
AND NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THESE TOXIC CHEMICALS THANK YOU.
OKAY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREA VENTURE
WITH CLEAN WATER ACTION WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THESE THINGS GO
DOWN THE DRAIN AS WELL.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
CATHERINE PORTER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HELPING ELSE LONG
COLLABORATIVE ANSWER FOR A SAN
FRANCISCO PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE SEVEN PLEAD ON BEHALF OF
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS AND THE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN THIS
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT.
JOINING LEYVA CONSTITUENT FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MONTAGES DISTRICT
AND SUPPORT.
MALINA FRANCESCHI INTERN WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THE NET MONTHLY AS YOU SEE SAN
DIEGO AND SUPPORT.
MORE IN COMMON BE HAVE A SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
KEVIN INS CO FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
THEN I'D LIKE THE OPPOSITION TO
COME UP AND DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE
WHO WERE SUPPORTERS CAN -- ALLOW
FOR SOME SPACE AT THE TABLE
.
WELL DOCTOR QUIRK AND MEMBERS OF
ES T. M. -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS A J. AND SELLING A VICE
PRESIDENT OF COSMETIC PROGRAMS
AT THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNSEL.
ON BOTH A PHD CHEMIST IN A BOARD
CERTIFIED TOXICOLOGIST AND I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
OPPOSITION TO BILL. FOR NINETY
FIVE THIS BILL PROPOSES AN
OUTRIGHT BAN ON MANY INGREDIENTS
EXTENSIVELY REVIEWED BY
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS WORLDWIDE
AND FOUND SAFE FOR USE IN
COSMETICS.
THE BAND WOULD ADVERSELY AFFECT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PRODUCTS
AND POTENTIALLY COMPROMISE THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE CONSUMERS
WITH THE SAFE HIGH QUALITY
PRODUCTS THEY EXPECT.
SIMPLY STATED NO OTHER AUTHORITY
IN THE WORLD AGREES THAT AN
OUTRIGHT BAN ON MANY OF THESE
INGREDIENTS IS NEEDED OR
JUSTIFIED.
MORE SPECIFICALLY PC PC AS
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
FIVE FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
US FEDERAL LAW GOVERNING
COSMETICS AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS ABSOLUTELY REQUIRES
THAT COSMETIC PRODUCTS
INGREDIENTS MUST BE SAFE FOR
CONSUMERS.
AND THAT COMPANIES AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO MARKET COSMETICS
ARE LEGALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
SHARING THEIR SAFETY.
FEDERAL LAW BOTH PROVIDES
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY.
AND SET SEVERE PENALTIES FOR
PRODUCT MANUFACTURERS THAT DO
NOT MEET THE STRICT REQUIREMENTS.
THE LAW DOES ALLOW INSPECTION OF
FACILITIES ISSUING A WARNING
LETTERS REQUESTING VOLUNTARY
RECALLS.
AND ISSUING A PRESS RELEASES.
AND WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
GIVE THE AUTHORITY TO ISSUE A
RESTRAINING ORDERS PRODUCTS
SEIZURES UP TO AND INCLUDING
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION.
THIS BILL A BILL WOULD BAN WHOLE
CLASSES OF PRESERVATIVES HOUSTON
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PRODUCTS.
THESE PRESERVATIVES ARE WIDELY
USED TO HAVE BEEN REVIEWED AND
FOUND SAFE FOR COSMETICS BY
AUTHORITIES BOTH WITHIN AND
OUTSIDE THE U. S..
HAVING A SUITABLE POWER
PRESERVATIVES IS AN ESSENTIAL
REQUIREMENT.
IN COSMETIC FORMULATION SCIENCE
TO ASSURE THE PRODUCTS MAINTAIN
THEIR INTEGRITY OVER TIME.
PARTICULARLY DURING STORAGE AND
USED BY CONSUMERS.
LACK OF PROPER PRESERVATION CAN
LEAD TO CONTAMINATION OF
PRODUCTS WITH HARMFUL MARKER
ORGANISMS.
NEXT THE BILL PLACES A BAN ON
NATURALLY OCCURRING IMPURITIES
THAT ARE FOUND IN EVERYTHING
FROM THE AIR WE BREATHE THE FOOD
AND WATER WE DRINK.
LET FOR EXAMPLE IS NEVER
INTENTIONALLY ADDED.
IT CAN HOWEVER BE FOUND A TRACE
AMOUNTS IN WATER AND SOIL AND
THEREFORE MAY ALSO BE FOUND AT
EXTREMELY LOW LEVELS AS A TRACE
CONTAMINANT IN MANY RAW
MATERIALS.
MANUFACTURERS AND REGULATORY
BODIES AROUND THE WORLD KNOW
THIS.
AND HAVE ALREADY ADDRESSED THE
ISSUE.
IT'S AN IMPURITY IN COSMETICS
LIMITS HAVE BEEN SET -- IN THE
THE US AND CANADA BRAZIL.
THE EUROPEAN UNION EVEN
CALIFORNIA'S OWN -- WE HA HAS
SET NO SIGNIFICANT RISK LEVELS
FOR LEAD AND THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER ACT.
FINALLY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT THE LEGISLATURE AGREED
THAT THE BEST VENUE FOR SCIENCE
BASED DECISIONS.
AS WITH THE DTS SEE AND STATE.
AGENCY SCIENTISTS.
THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS LAW
WAS ENACTED SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD NOT BE FACED
WITH BILLS LIKE.
FOUR NINETY FIVE WHICH PUTS THEM
IN THE POSITION OF MAKING
COMPLEX SCIENCE DECISIONS.
IN FACT A BEFORE NINETY FIVE
CONTRADICTS SO HE HOUSE OWN
EXPERTS.
HOUSE OF PROPOSING OUTRIGHT BANS
ON SEVERAL CHEMICALS ALREADY
ADDRESSED.
OR CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW BY D.
TSC.
AT A MINIMUM A CALIFORNIA SHOULD
LET THE TSC CONTINUE ITS ROLE
THAT WAS GIVEN BY THIS
LEGISLATURE BEFORE STEPPING IN.
AND NTRODUCING ADDITIONAL
REGULATIONS.
IN SUMMARY THE BILL PROPOSES TO
BAN INGREDIENTS THE PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE.
IN ASSURING THE SAFETY OF
COSMETICS RELIED ON BY CONSUMERS.
ADDRESSES SUBSTANCES THAT ARE
NOT AND WOULD NOT BE USED AS
INGREDIENTS.
AN INMATE AWAITS CONFLICTS WITH
THE CONCLUSIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S
OWN EXPERTS. FOR ALL THE REASONS
ABOVE WE OPPOSE AB.
FOR NINETY FIVE AND WE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
VIEWS.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU -- DON CAP KIßM HALF
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OF FIRST
I'D LIKE TO APOLOGIZE TO BE
OFFERED TO THE COMMITTEE -- WE
DID INTEND FOR NAME TO BE LISTED
IN THE NOW SUSPECTED JUST STILL
GETTING USED TO THAT PORTAL
MECHANISM OUT FOR FORMALLY BEING
LISTED SO I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
I NONE THE LESS THE MTA IS IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION -- TO
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FIVE I HAD
KIND OF BUILDING UPON THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE AND WE
DO BELIEVE THAT THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM IS THE RIGHT
SPACE FOR LOOKING ATTY
INGREDIENTS CHEMICALS IN
PRODUCTS IN THE LEGISLATURE IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT PASS THAT
LEGISLATION TO DO EXACTLY THAT
WITH CONCERNS OVER MAKING
SCIENTIFIC DECISIONS EVALUATING --
KIND OF NEAR THE TRADE OFFS IN
THE VARIOUS WEIGHTING FACTORS
BETWEEN NOT ONLY THE CHEMICAL IN
QUESTION BUT ALSO -- ITS USE IN
THAT PRODUCT AND ANY POTENTIAL
ALTERNATIVES FURTHER THE LAW WAS
PASSED IN A WITH THE INTEREST OF
KIND OF LOOKING AT A ROBUST --
LIST OF FACTORS TO EVALUATE
POTENTIAL TRADE OFFS BETWEEN YOU
KNOW ENVIRONMENTAL.
IMPACTS ON HUMAN HEALTH IMPACTS --
AND A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUAL A
PARTICULAR A SPECIFIED IMPACTS
IN IN KIND OF THOSE CATEGORIES
I'M IN WITH REGARD TO A BEFORE
NINETY FIVE AS WAS MENTIONED IT
DOES TAKE ON APPROACH LOOKING
OUT BEGINNING.
A CHEMICAL INGREDIENTS THAT MAY
BE USED IN THESE PRODUCTS A
NUMBER OF THEM -- MAY NOT BE BUT
NONE THE LESS THE PROGRAM IS SET
UP TO EVALUATE THAT LOOK AT THE
TRADE OFFS I'M LOOK AT IT.
LESSENING EXPOSURE WHERE THERE
MAY NOT BE ALTERNATIVES
AVAILABLE -- BUT ALSO LOOK AT
VARIOUS KIND OF THRESHOLD BUT
MAYBE SET BY SOME OF THE MOST
STRINGENT ON BODIES ARE BOTH IN
STATE AS WELL AS ON THE NATION
AND WORLD LIKE A WE HARDLY
OFFICE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT.
WHICH DOES SETS ARE PRETTY
STRINGENT LIMITS WE WOULD ARGUE
FROM THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY SOME
OF THE MOST STRINGENT LIMITS
THERE ARE WHEN IT COMES -- TO
CHEMICALS AND CHEMICAL
REGULATION.
IN TERMS OF ONE OF THE WORK THAT
DTS HE HAS UNDER WAY NOW AND AS
YOU MAY BE AWARE THEIR WORK PLAN
DOES CURRENTLY ON THAT THEY ARE
LOOKING AT INCLUDED -- BEAUTY
PERSONAL CARE AND HYGIENE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE IN SCOPE FOR
THEIR REVIEW CURRENTLY IN THIS
CURRENT -- PROCESS AND EVEN MORE
SO THEY'VE ACTUALLY MOVE MADE
THE MOVES AND ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON A DEVELOPMENT OF
REGULATIONS SPECIFIC TO ONE OF
THE LISTED CHEMICAL INGREDIENTS
IN THE BILL TAL EWING AND NAIL
PRODUCTS.
SO I THINK IT IS INDICATING
INDICATIVE OF THE FACT THAT THE
PROCESS IS WORKING AND THEY ARE
LOOKING OUT.
OF THESE TYPES OF INGREDIENT
POTENTIAL INGREDIENTS AND
ALTERNATIVES IN THESE TYPES OF
PRODUCTS UNDERSTANDING AND
HEARING FROM STAKEHOLDERS OF
THAT THERE IS AN INTEREST THERE
ARE CONCERNS WITH REGARD TO THAT.
FURTHER I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
PROCESS DOES ALLOW FOR A
PETITION PROCESS FOR
STAKEHOLDERS A TO REQUEST FOR
THE REVIEW OF INDIVIDUAL
CHEMICAL PRODUCT COMBINATIONS
ARE SO THAT ALSO IS ANOTHER
MECHANISM ALSO.
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO PUT
THOSE HANDS IN THE DECISION OF
SCIENTISTS SO WITH THAT WE DO --
BELIEVE THAT THAT PROCESS IS A
MORE APPROPRIATE FOR THESE TYPES
OF OUR PRODUCT INGREDIENT
CHEMICAL BEYOND DISCUSSIONS --
AND LEAVES OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
SCIENTISTS TO MAKE THE DECISIONS
AS TO WHETHER TO LESSEN EXPOSURE
BASED ON KIND OF OTHER.
MECHANISMS BY YOU KNOW LIMóN
EIGHTEEN ADDING POTENTIAL
INGREDIENT IN QUESTION
EVALUATING THE TRADE OFFS
BETWEEN THAT AND POTENTIAL
ALTERNATIVES TO AVOID
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTES.
AND THE LIKE SO WITH THAT -- WE
RESPECTFULLY MUST OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD.
OF OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
BAKLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH PC
PCNC MTA WERE IN OPPOSITION
THANKS.
THANK YOU.
JULIE MAN ASK ABOUT THEY HAVE
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
OPPOSES WELL.
THANK YOU.
NO CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE
FRAGRANCE CREATORS ASSOCIATION
THE HOUSEHOLD COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION ALSO
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT -- IF THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE WANTS TO SPEAK THEN WE'LL
GO TO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEN NO QUESTIONS -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING STATEMENT
OF COURSE WERE THIS IS NOT FOR
VOTE AT THE MOMENT THIS IS A
CLOSING STATEMENT AND YOU CAN
HAVE ONE OF YOUR EXPERTS COME UP --
IF THEY'D LIKE -- IN CASE THERE
IS.
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO REFER TO
THEM.
OKAY WELL -- AGAIN I WOULD
INVITE ANY QUESTIONS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE EXPERTISE THAT
I FEEL LIKE WE HAVE NOT BEEN.
ABLE TO TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF
IT THAT -- HERE TODAY BUT TO
AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY -- TO
GIVING US THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT -- WHAT WE FEEL -- AND
IS A COMPELLING CASE THAT OVER
FORTY NATIONS HAVE A READY
EITHER BANNED OR RESTRICTED MANY
OF THESE CHEMICALS I MEAN FIRST
OF ALL LET'S START WITH THE LIST
OF CHEMICALS BECAUSE I KNOW OF
HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT.
THE LIST OF THE THE CHEMICALS I
THINK THERE ARE.
YOU KNOW SOME CHEMICALS THAT WE
SHOULD ALL BE OF THE GREE ON
THAT HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO PLACE IN
ANY -- COSMETICS YES YEAH I
THINK WE CAN COULD SEE FOR THAT
YEAH THAT FOR LEAD US BEST DOES
IN MERCURY FOR SURE THANK YOU
SIR AND SO YOU KNOW I YOU KNOW.
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF SHOWS THE
SHORT COMING WHY THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM HAS FAILED TO
ENSURE THAT AS BEST THIS IS NOT
FOUND IN THE TALC OF PRODUCTS
YOU KNOW WHY WE ARE FOUND OF
FINDING.
THE CHEMICALS THAT WE CAN AGREE
ON BEING SOLD TO OUR OUR YOU
KNOW OUR YOUNG GIRLS ARE
TEENAGERS ESPECIALLY GAL --
YOUNG WOMEN OF CHILDBEARING AGE
YOU KNOW.
THESE THESE CHEMICALS -- THAT
HAPPENED FOUND AND PRODUCTS LIKE
CLAIRE'S LIKE JUSTICE AS AS THE
YOU KNOW -- THE IDENTIFIED IN IN
YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND AND
I I THINK THE IN TERMS OF THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM WHILE WE
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY -- HERE THE
ARGUMENT OFTEN THAT -- WITH THAT
WE SHOULD LET THE SCIENTISTS THE
DETERMINE RATHER THAN
LEGISLATORS AYE AYE AYE THING AT
AGAIN AS YOUR COMMITTEE AND ALSO
IT'S CLEARLY.
IDENTIFIES EVER SINCE THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM WAS STARTED IN
IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE THE PROGRAM
HAS ONLY -- IDENTIFIED THREE
PRODUCT CHEMICAL COMBINATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN CURRENTLY FILE
FINALIZED AND THREE MORE IN
VARIOUS STAGES OF THE PROGRAM IN
THE MEANTIME WE CONTINUE TO HAVE.
YOU KNOW THESE HIGHLY TOXIC
CHEMICALS THAT WE YOU KNOW WE
SOME OF WHICH WE ALL OF US
SHOULD BE A DEGREE ON AND OTHERS
WE YOU KNOW WE WE CERTAINLY WILL
BE.
YOU KNOW ARE OPEN TO
CONVERSATIONS IN TERMS OF OF THE
SPECIFIC CHEMICALS THAT -- THAT
WE WE WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS SO
THAT WE SHOULD ADDRESS AND THOSE
THAT PERHAPS YOU KNOW WE WE CAN
TALK ABOUT LEAVING OFFER.
SOME OTHER CHEMICALS THAT ARE ON
THIS LIST WE ARE ALSO HAPPY TO
TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW A A PHASE OUT PERIOD IN
TERMS OF ENSURING THAT WERE
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS --
BY BY GIVING -- THAT THE
INDUSTRY BY GIVING MANUFACTURERS
ENOUGH TIME TO TO TRY TO PHASE
OUT SOME OF THESE.
THESE INGREDIENTS BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
PROGRAM IS AS FAILED TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AS FAILED
TO ENSURE.
THAT THE THE THAT THAT THESE
HIGHLY TOXIC CHEMICAL SO YOU
KNOW THAT ARE NOT IN A CANNOT.
THE ARE NOT TO BE FOUND IN AND
PRODUCTS BEING SOLD TO OUR OUR
OUR IN THE TWO GIRLS WOMEN AND
MEN -- AND AND AND THAT -- THE
STATUS QUO IS NOT ACCEPTABLE AND
SO -- YOU KNOW I I WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION.
AS THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE
COMING TO YOUR BILL -- AND I
WOULD WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MANY MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
THAT -- TO IN A AS TO HOW WE CAN --
ALL COME TOGETHER TO TO AGREE ON
A PLAN TO PROTECT -- YOU KNOW.
WOMEN GIRLS AND AND AND AND MEN
THAT THAT THAT -- CONSUME THESE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS ON A
DAILY BASIS.
AND SO -- I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY -- FIRST DIED IN IN -- I'D
LIKE TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS I
AGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION THAT.
I'VE GOT LEAD IN MY HAIR ON MY
LIPS IT'S EVERYWHERE -- BUT WE
WERE ASKING FOR AN AMENDMENT TO
IT SAYING THAT FOR NATURAL
OCCURRING ELEMENTS.
THAT IS SO LONG AS IT'S A THE
MINIMUS AMOUNT AND I CAN'T SAY
WHETHER AND CLAIRE'S WAS TO
DIMINISH IN THE MINIMUM OUT OF
AS BEST AS TO NOT.
BUT GIVEN THE STATE OF
ANALYTICAL CHEMISTRY WE CAN
DETECT VIRTUALLY ANY CHEMICAL
ANYWHERE SO I WOULD LIKE.
TO AGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
THAT THAT WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL ABOUT THE REGULATIONS
THAT WE BRING FORWARD.
I WANT TO AGREE WITH -- MISTER
MURATSUCHI THAT WE CAN'T DEPEND
UPON GREEN CHEMISTRY.
NOR DO WE FRANKLY NEED TO FOR
LEAD OR ASBESTOS OR MERCURY.
THERE OTHER CHEMICALS IN HERE
HAVING TALKED WITH THE
OPPOSITION I DON'T THINK THERE
IS A GOOD CASE FOR BEING MADE
FOR PUTTING THEM ON THIS LIST --
AND WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS TO
WORK WITH BOTH THAT PROPONENTS
AND OPPONENTS SO THAT COME.
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF TIME -- THAT --
I HAVE A LIST THAT I'M
COMFORTABLE WITH AND THAT LIST
HAS TO BE ONE WHERE THE
CHEMICALS WERE TALKING ABOUT.
OUR BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
[inaudible]
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE TO VOTE
ON NEW SCIENCE I DON'T WANT THEM
TO SAY WELL THIS IS IN BAND
ANYWHERE BUT WE'RE GOING TO BAN
IT.
I THINK THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE.
I DO THINK WHEN THERE'S A
CONSENSUS AND I'VE MENTIONED LET
US BEST TO SUE MERCURY.
THAT WE ARE TO REACH CONSENSUS
AND HOW MANY OF THESE ARE.
HEARING FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT
IN FACT A LOT OF THESE THEY DO
NO LONGER USE -- NEVER NEVER
USED -- WE COULD PROBABLY
INCLUDE THOSE THERE OTHERS THAT
ARE WILL PROBABLY STRIKE FROM
THIS LIST BUT WHAT I DON'T WANT
IS.
WHAT I DO WANT IS WHEN THERE'S
GENERAL AGREEMENT THAT
SOMETHING'S A AN ISSUE THAT IT'S
BEEN SEEN BY THE VARIOUS?
AUTHORITIES TO BE AN ISSUE THEN
WE CAN AGREE ON IT AND IF IT'S
IN QUESTION.
WE HAVE TO THINK VERY HARD
BEFORE WE MAKE A DECISION SO I
SEE YOU NODDING YES.
ARE SO WE WILL WORK CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BE -- ON
ALL SIDES FOR BEING OPEN I WILL
SAY THAT ONE OF THE GREAT
DIFFICULTIES OF THIS SPELL.
WAS THAT BECAUSE OUR PROCESS.
FOR LETTING AMENDMENTS OUT WAS
SO SLOW THIS YEAR AND PROBABLY
OTHER YEARS AS WELL.
THERE SIMPLY WASN'T TIME TO DO
ALL THE WORK THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO DO AND I DO WANT TO SAY FOR
THOSE WHO ARE CARRYING THE MORE
CONTROVERSIAL BILLS.
IF YOU CAN LET US KNOW IN THE
FALL THAT YOU'RE DOING THE BILL.
AND WE CAN WORK WITH -- THE
INDUSTRY AT THE SAME TIME --
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL TO US
ALL SO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
AND WE CAN GET ON TO MISTER
MERCY CHEESE NEXT BELL AND THEN
TO MISTER BLOOM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I'M COMING DOWN AGAIN AND
GIVING THEM THIS TO THE VICE
CHAIR [inaudible] SEVEN SEVEN
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
OKAY I'M OKAY WE ARE ITEM SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE ONE TWO RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO AB NOT
ACTUALLY AND A. B. NINE ONE TWO
THE BALLAST WATER.
A BILL THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION TO
CONTINUE TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
OCEAN ECOSYSTEM BY FIGHTING THE
INTRODUCTION OF MARINE INVASIVE
SPECIES INTO OUR WATERS.
INVASIVE SPECIES DISRUPT
SHIPPING OPERATIONS AS WELL AS
COMMERCIAL FISHING AND DAMAGES
DAMAGES NATIVE HABITATS AND
SPECIES.
INVASIVE SPECIES ACCOUNT FOR UP
TO ONE HUNDRED TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR IN ECONOMIC
LOSSES ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
SHIPPING INDUSTRY ADDITIONAL
TIME TO DEVELOP THE TECHNOLOGY
NECESSARY TO MEET CALIFORNIA
STRONG ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS
AT THE SAME TIME THIS BILL WILL
GIVE THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
THE AUTHORITY. TO ENFORCE
FEDERAL STANDARDS WHILE
COLLECTING DATA TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN THOSE STANDARDS GOING
FORWARD I WOULD LIKE TO TURN
OVER TO SHARE PEMBERTON -- WITH
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
THANK YOU I SHERRY PEMBERTON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LANDS COMMISSION IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE TWELVE AND WE'RE ALSO
THE SPONSOR OF AB.
NINE TWELVE AND IMPLEMENT THE
COMMISSION'S MARINE INVASIVE
SPECIES PROGRAM THERE ARE.
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS FOR
DISCHARGE BALLAST WATER THAT
WERE ESTABLISHED MANY YEARS AGO
AND ARE SCHEDULED TO BE PHASED
IN STARTING IN JANUARY.
HOWEVER THERE ISN'T TECHNOLOGY
AVAILABLE AND FORTUNATELY FOR
REASONS OUTSIDE OF OUR CONTROL
TO MEET THOSE STANDARDS.
SO THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
TIME WHEN THERE MAY BE STANDARDS
AVAILABLE ALSO TO POSITION THE
STATE.
THROUGH THE COMMISSION TO FIGHT
FOR THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE
STANDARDS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
AND WE WOULD DO THAT BY --
ENFORCING NATIONAL STANDARDS AND
CHECKING ENOUGH AND ASSESSING
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S INSTALLED ON
VESSELS -- WE HAVE A TECHNICAL
ADVISORY GROUP WITH A BROAD
ARRAY OF STAKEHOLDERS TO INFORM
OUR ASSESSMENT OF WHETHER
TECHNOLOGIES AVAILABLE.
IT'S A VERY PUBLIC AND
TRANSPARENT -- PROCESS AND
EVERYONE'S WELCOME TO
PARTICIPATE SO WE JUST WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THAT AS THE BASIS FOR
HOW WE ARRIVE AT OUR ASSESSMENT
OF WHETHER TECHNOLOGY IS
AVAILABLE.
AND SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON
AB [inaudible]
NINE TWELVE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY -- SO WE'VE HEARD FROM YOUR
EXPERT WITNESS -- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
THE NOTION THAT.
THERE HAS BEEN -- THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I ASKED WHERE I'VE
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
NINE TWELVE MODES TO CHEAT THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE AYE KALRA
[inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN DALY.
DALY I'D CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MATHIS.
WHAT'S THE GI IN A TO G.. FIVE
TWO ITEM.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
WE'RE ON TO OUR NEXT BILL --
MISTER BLOOM WITH A V. SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO SOLID WASTE
FLUSHABLE PRODUCTS.
AND WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO MAKE
BATHROOM DRUG.
WHAT MADE THIS MY FAVORITE?
I JUST MADE ONE BUT I'M THE
CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
WELL.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM IN MY HANDS --
THIS IS -- TOILET PAPER THAT HAS
BEEN IN THIS JAR FOR
APPROXIMATELY A DAY AND YOU CAN
SEE IT'S DISSOLVING AND IN
LITTLE PIECES.
THIS IS A JAR OF IT'S VERY CUTE
TUG OF BOOZE KIDS WIPES -- SOLD
AT RITE AID AND PUT IN THE JAR
OF WATER IT ON FEBRUARY NOW IS
THIS MARKS IS FLUSHABLE.
YEAH YES OKAY -- AND AS YOU CAN
SEE IT'S IN ONE PIECE.
AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM -- AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD AN IMPORTANT
BILL THAT SEEKS TO PROVIDE CLEAR
CONSUMER INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
CONSUMERS SHOULD PROPERLY
DISPOSE OF SINGLE USE WET WIPES
PRODUCTS.
WITH THE INTENT OF KEEPING NON
DISPERSIBLE WIPES OUT OF OUR
SEWER SYSTEM.
IN THE LAST FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
YEARS THERE'S BEEN A
PROLIFERATION OF SINGLE USE WHAT
WHITE.
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE COME INTO THE
RETAIL MARKET.
MANY OF THESE PRODUCTS ARE
INTENDED TO BE DISPOSED OF IN
THE TRASH CAN HOWEVER THERE'S A
GROWING SUITE OF PRODUCTS THAT
ARE MARKETED AS FLUSHABLE OR
SEWER AND SEPTIC SAFE.
AND CURRENTLY THERE SIMPLY ARE
NO FEDERAL STATE DEFINITIONS OF
WHAT CONSTITUTES A FLUSHABLE
CONSUMER PRODUCT IN IT AS A
RESULT.
ANY COMPANY CAN CALL.
ANY PRODUCT FLUSHABLE REGARDLESS
OF THE POTENTIAL HARM TO THE
SEWER SYSTEM OR WHETHER IT TRULY
BREAKS APART LIKE TOILET PAPER
ONCE IT IS FLUSHED.
WHEN WET WHITE PRODUCTS ARE
FLUSHED INTO THE SEWER SYSTEM
THEY CAN CAUSE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES FOR PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS SEWER COLLECTIONS AND
WASTE TREATMENT PLANTS?
SINGLE USE WET WIPES ARE HEAVIER
THICKER AND HAVE LARGER SURFACE
AREAS THAN TOILET PAPER.
AND RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND THAT
UNDER WET CONDITIONS WIPES
MAINTAIN MOST OF THEIR STRENGTH
AS THEIR COMPOSED OF SYNTHETIC
FIBERS THAT RETAIN THEIR SHAPE
AND STRENGTH.
WHITE SO OFTEN DO NOT BREAK DOWN
AFTER BEING FLUSHED AND THEY CAN
ACCUMULATE WITH FATS OILS AND
GREASE AND BECOME LARGE
OBSTRUCTIONS IN OUR PIPES.
FURTHER DOWN THE LINE THEY WEAVE
TOGETHER AND CREATE GIANT RAGS
WHICH CAN GET STUCK AND PUMPS
COLLECTION SYSTEMS AND MOTORS.
AND BECAUSE BACKUPS AND
EQUIPMENT FAILURES.
THIS PROBLEM IS EXPERIENCE
ACROSS THE STATE COUNTRY AND
WORLDWIDE AS DISPOSABLE WET
WHITE PRODUCTS BECOME MORE
WIDELY AVAILABLE.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE TREATMENT
PLANTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA -- ARE
THE THESE TREATMENT PLANTS ARE
WAY TOO FAMILIAR WITH THE SCORCH
OF WET WIPES.
BEING IMPROPERLY FLUSHED IN SOME
CITIES SUCH AS PETALUMA COSTLY
SCREENING FACILITIES HAVE FAILED
TO STOP THESE IN DISPERSIBLE
PRODUCTS FROM FINDING THEIR WAY
THROUGH THE WASTE WATER SYSTEM.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE ORANGE
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICT
CONDUCTED NEARLY ONE THOUSAND
PREVENTATIVE OR CORRECTIVE
EITHER THE WORD FOR THIS.
D. RAGGING MAINTENANCE CALLS ON
ME WHO.
CALLS ON AT TEN OF THEIR FIFTEEN
REGIONAL PUMP STATIONS THIS
COSTUME ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE CITY OF CAMROSE WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANT HAS INVESTED A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS TO UPGRADE
ITS WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANT.
THE PUMP SYSTEMS TO MANAGE THE
VOLUME OF WIPES PASSING THROUGH
THE SYSTEM ON A DAILY BASIS AND
IN EACH OF THESE CASES OF COURSE
THE COST GETS PASSED ON TO RATE
PAYERS AND TAXPAYERS.
THIS BILL PRESCRIBES CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT CONSUMER MESSAGING
FOR THESE PRODUCTS THAT
INDICATES TO CONSUMERS THAT
EITHER A WIFE AS FLUSHABLE.
OR IT'S NOT.
UNDER THESE PROVISIONS WIPES CAN
BE LABELED AS FLUSHABLE IF THEY
DO NOT CAUSE HARM TO THE SEWER
SYSTEM MEANING THAT
MANUFACTURERS CAN DEMONSTRATE
THAT THEIR WIVES CAN BREAK DOWN
IN THE SEWER SYSTEM.
LIKE DRY TOILET PAPER. FOR ALL
OTHER WIPES THAT ARE NOT
INTENDED TO BE FLUSHED THEY MUST
BE MARKED WITH THE DO NOT FLUSH
LABEL.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS JESSICA GALLAGHER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER -- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN QUIRK IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
JUST C<c.cyan> AUGER WITH THE</c>
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCY IS -- HERE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
SINGLE USE WHAT WEIGHT
SURVEILLANCE HAVE LEE -- NEW
PRODUCT ON THE MARKET AND
THERE'S A DIRECT CORRELATION
WITH THE INCREASING POPULARITY --
OF SINGLE USE WET WIPES PRODUCTS
AND THE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS
THAT WE'RE SEEING.
IN THE SEWER SYSTEM WITH RAGGING --
THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF
INCONSISTENCY IN HOW WIPES
PRODUCTS ARE LABELED AND HOW
CONSUMERS ARE GIVEN INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT'S SAFE TO FLUSH AND
WHAT ISN'T.
THE RESULT IS AN ONSLAUGHT OF
WIPES BEING FLUSHED DOWN THE
DRAIN BOTH WHITE THAT ARE
LABELED AS FLUSHABLE AND THOSE
THAT AREN'T INTENDED TO BE
FLASHED AND THEY'RE CAUSING
MAJOR PROBLEMS FOR SEWER SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
YOU'VE ALL PROBABLY HEARD THE
TERM IT'S GROSS FAT BERG AND
THESE ARE GIANT OBSTRUCTIONS OF
WIPES MIXED WITH OTHER GROSS
STUFF LIKE GREECE AND THEY ARE
MAJORLY DESTRUCTIVE FOR THE US
SYSTEMS.
AND CAN CAUSE SANITARY SEWER
OVERFLOWS A SEWER SPILL OF ANY
AMOUNT IS THE PUBLIC AN
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARD WE SHOULD
DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE -- TO
AVOID THEM.
LAST YEAR ALONE NEARLY A HUNDRED
SANITARY SEWER OVERFLOWS WERE
ATTRIBUTED TO WIPES BLOCKAGES
AND THOSE WERE REPORTED TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD BY PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND THAT NUMBER DOESN'T
ACCOUNT. FOR THE OVER FLOWS AND
AT PRIVATE RESIDENCES OR
BUSINESSES THAT AREN'T SUBJECT
TO RECORDING.
ONCE WIPES GET FURTHER DOWN IN
THE SYSTEMS OF LARGE RAGS
COMBINED WITH OTHER DEBRIS GET
WRAPPED UP IN HEAVY MECHANICAL
FEATURES LIKE PUMPS.
AND MOTORS AND SCREENS REQUIRING
ADDITIONAL MAINTENANCE OR
REPLACEMENT OF THE STRUCTURES
THE CONSTANT REMEDIATION EFFORTS
DISRUPT ALL STAGES OF THE
TREATMENT PROCESS AND RESULT IN
COSTS ON MANY LEVELS FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND ULTIMATELY RATE
PAYERS.
I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
MANY WIPES CONTAIN PLASTIC AND
DON'T ABIDE.
BY ANY -- LABELING CODE OF
PRACTICE AND WHEN THOSE ARE
FLASH THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
LOADINGS OF MICRO PLASTICS AND
WASTEWATER EFFLUENT.
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT TIME ENERGY
AND PUBLIC MONEY BEING SPENT ON
MASSIVE PUBLIC EDUCATION EFFORTS
ABOUT THE PROBLEMS WITH FLUSHING
WIPES.
PRETTY MUCH EVERY AGENCY HAS
DONE OUT REACH ABOUT WIPES FOR
MANY YEARS AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE EDUCATIONAL CAMPAIGN
SIMPLY AREN'T EFFECTIVE ENOUGH
AND MANAGING THIS PROBLEM WE
KNOW THAT PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH.
ALONE ISN'T SUFFICIENT BECAUSE
WE'VE ALSO DONE PARALLEL
CUSTOMER OUT REACH ON FAT SOILS
INCREASE FOR DECADES AND IT
CONTINUES TO ALSO BE A PROBLEM.
IN OUR SYSTEMS WE RECENTLY DID
SOME POLLING ON THIS ISSUE IN
THE BAY AREA AND BY A LARGE
MARGIN IT WAS EVIDENT THAT
CONSUMERS TRUST THE LABELING ON
PACKAGES AND THAT IS THEIR
PREFERRED METHOD FOR RECEIVING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROPER
DISPOSAL OF THESE PRODUCTS.
FAR AND ABOVE HEARING ABOUT IT
FROM THEIR LOCAL SEWER UTILITY
THE PERFORMANCE METRICS FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN THIS BILL ARE
BASED ON SCIENCE AND THEY
ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
CONDITIONS IN THE SEWER.
ESPECIALLY IN THE SYSTEMS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE'S LESS
TURBULENCE BECAUSE OF SUCCESSFUL
WATER CONSERVATION EFFORTS.
THE METRICS WERE DEVELOPED BY AN
INTERNATIONAL GROUP OF MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED PUBLIC WASTE WATER
ENTITIES USING A SCIENTIFIC AN
EVIDENCE BASED PROCESS WITH
FEEDBACK FROM THE NON WOVEN
FABRICS INDUSTRY.
DO NOT FLUSH LABELING
REQUIREMENT IS IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE VOLUNTARY INDUSTRY
GUIDELINES THAT MANY OF THESE
PRODUCTS ALREADY ABIDE BY.
IT'S TIME TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM AND REQUIRING
MANUFACTURERS TO PROVIDE CLEAR
CONSUMER INFORMATION ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATE DISPOSAL OF THESE
PRODUCTS.
IS A SENSIBLE AND MODERATE
APPROACH FOR THESE REASONS WERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEES I
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIR IN GREEN
WITH THE SANITATION DISTRICTS OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND WE'RE HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOE Là MERRY ON
A RETHINK WAYS AND SAN MATTEO
COUNTY WERE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN ANTI TUG
OF SO THANK YOU.
EMILY BARNETT ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRAL CONTRA COSTA SANITARY
DISTRICT AND THE DOUBLE MEANT A
SAN RAMON SERVICES DISTRICT ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
STOP WASTE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL AND
SALAS WASTE ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA IN SUPPORT.
BONNIE MANY ON THE BEHALF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
SUPPORT.
Q. SEALY ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE ABIT ON ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
AND ANDREA VENTURE WITH CLEAN
WATER ACTION IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD -- WITH THE OPPOSITION
LIKE TO COME UP TO THE FRONT
TABLE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR QUIRK AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CHRIS ROSE ON
BEHALF OF INTO THE ASSOCIATION
OF NON WOVEN FABRIC INDUSTRY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON AB.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO WE BELIEVE
THE BEST SOLUTIONS FOR
ADDRESSING WASTE WATER SYSTEM
CLOGS REQUIRE THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF DATA DRIVEN
WASTE WATER SYSTEM STUDIES.
IN THIS IS THE FOUNDATION FOR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE PICTURES OF
THE BIG UGLY CLOGS THAT ARE
PULLED OUT OF SYSTEMS MANY SUCH
PICTURES APPEAR TO INVOLVE WIPES
OR RAGGING MATERIAL THERE WIDELY
REPORTED.
AS FLUSHABLE WIPES HOWEVER AFTER
SEVERAL FORENSIC ANALYSES OF
MAJOR CLOGS IN THE UNITED STATES
AND IN THE U. K. WE KNOW THIS IS
MOSTLY THE CASE OF MISTAKEN
IDENTITY.
THE WASTEWATER COLLECTION
STUDIES INDICATE THAT POSSIBLE
WIPES ARE NOT THE PRIMARY CAUSES
OF CLOGS AND SEWER SYSTEMS. FOR
EXAMPLE COMPREHENSIVE STUDY IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN IN NEW YORK CITY
ADMINISTERED BY AN INDEPENDENT
ENGINEERING FIRM AT THE REQUEST
OF THE NEW YORK CITY LAW
DEPARTMENT.
FOUND FLUSHABLE WIPES WERE THE
SMALLEST CATEGORY OF MATERIALS
COLLECTED AT 2%.
THIS SHOWS THAT THE IN THE
FLEXIBILITY GUIDELINES
GUIDELINES FOR WIPES ACTUALLY
WORK AS INTENDED AND THAT
FLUSHABLE WIPES ARE NOT THE
SOURCE OF THE PRIMARY PROBLEM
WHICH IS CONTRARY. TO THE STATED
PURPOSE OF AB.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO JUST AS NEW
YORK CITY CONDUCTED A FORENSIC
ANALYSIS OF THEIR CLOGS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE UNITED
KINGDOM STUDY BY WASTE WATER
SECTOR REPRESENTATIVES WATER U.
K. USE SIMILAR PROTOCOLS AND
COLLECTED AND ANALYZED MORE THAN
FIFTY CLOGS IN PUMPS SEWER
BLOCKAGES AND WASTE WATER
TREATMENT AND LET SAMPLES.
OVER A PERIOD OF MORE THAN TWO
MONTHS UPON COMPLETION
RESEARCHERS FOUND THAT FLUSHABLE
WIPES ACCOUNTED FOR A NEGLIGIBLE
AMOUNT OF IDENTIFIABLE MATERIAL
LESS THAN 2%.
THE SOURCE OF THE PROBLEM WAS
THE FLUSHING OF MATERIALS MEANT
TO BE THROWN IN THE TRASH NON
FLUSHABLE MATERIALS SUCH AS
FEMININE HYGIENE PRODUCTS PAPER
TELLS BABY WIPES.
FURTHER A FORENSIC ANALYSIS IN
PORTLAND MAINE MORAGA CALIFORNIA
SOME REALLY SHOWED FLUSHABLE
WIPES TO REPRESENT ONLY A SMALL
PORTION OF MATERIALS COLLECTED
AND IDENTIFIED.
EVEN DATA COLLECTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD SANITARY SEWER
OVERFLOW REDUCTION PRO PROGRAM
ILLUSTRATES THAT THE INTO
FLEXIBILITY STANDARDS ARE
WORKING WELL AS THE STATE'S DATA.
SHOWS THAT FLUSHABLE WIPES
PRODUCTS ARE NOT THE CAUSES OF
OVERFLOWS ARE CLOGS.
DESPITE MULTIPLE REQUESTS THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL HAVE
NEVER PRODUCED ANY DATA SHOWING
THAT FLUSHABLE WIPES OR THE
SOURCES OF THE OBSTRUCTIONS IN
THEIR SYSTEMS.
THE DATA SCIENCE COMPREHENSIVE
STUDIES.
FORENSIC ANALYSES SHOW THAT THE
IN THE GUIDELINES WORK WHICH IS
WHY EUROPEAN COUNTRIES ARE
STEADILY INCREASING INDUSTRIES
KEY STANDARDS RATHER THAN THE
FAULTY STANDARD CONTAINED IN
THIS BILL.
THE FLEXIBILITY STANDARD IN A.
B. SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO IS SO
FLAWED THAT TESTING INDICATES TO
FAIL ALL FLUSHABLE WIPES ON THE
MARKET.
AND EVEN SOME DRY TOILET PAPERS.
THE BILL STANDARD EFFECTIVELY
BANS THE SALE OF FLUSHABLE WIPES
A PRODUCT SHOWN IN WASTE WATER
SYSTEMS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S OWN DATABASE TO NOT.
BE THE CAUSE OF OBSTRUCTIONS WE
WOULD ASK THE PROPONENTS WHY
THEY'RE CHOOSING A BAND OF WHAT
IS NO MORE THAN 2% OF THE
MATERIAL FOUND IN SYSTEMS.
WITH NO DATA TO SUGGEST -- IT'S
BEEN THREE AND A HALF MINUTES
DOES YOUR DOES THE OTHER PERSON
ONE THIS TIME HE IS HERE TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL OKAY GRASS
GOING TO WRAP UP.
SO WE WOULD HAVE TO PROPONENTS
WHETHER CHOOSING TO BAN
CHECK CHOOSING A BAN OF WHAT IS
NO MORE THAN 2% OF THE MATERIAL
FOUND IN SYSTEMS WITH NO DATA TO
SUGGEST IS THE PROBLEM RATHER
THAN FOCUSING ON 98%.
OF THE PROBLEM INDUSTRY
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT THE
PROMINENT DO NOT FLUSH LABELING
OF WHITE.
NOT ENGINEERED TO BE FLUSHED AND
WE ARE PLEASED TO WORK WITH CASA
ON TARGETED CAMPAIGN THAT
EMPOWERS ALL CALIFORNIANS TUMORS
TO MAKE.
BETTER DISPOSAL DISPOSAL SYSTEMS
I HAVE WITH ME JIM LEFT DOES THE
TECHNICAL EXPERT THAT CAN ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR DON CAP KIßM HALF
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THING.
THANK YOU.
RESEARCHER IN THREE MILLION ON
BEHALF THE GROCERY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THE COOKING HOURS ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION JUST WANNA
RAISE ONE ADDITIONAL ISSUE ON
THE CHANGES IN LABELING FOR
DISINFECTANT RIGHTS IN
PARTICULAR.
THOSE LABEL ANY LABEL CHANGE HAS
TO GO THROUGH -- APPROVAL BY THE
US EPA AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION SO AT A
MINIMUM THERE WE NEED TO BE TIME
BUILT IN TO ACCOMMODATE FOR
THOSE THAT TO JUST THINKING
THANK YOU.
KAREN ARE ALSO MAY HAVE THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNSEL
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
AT A RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE LINE OUR COMMENTS WITH I AND
I NDA OR POST THANKS.
OKAY JUST DUMB.
WELL THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION HERE I DON'T THINK
THAT IT'S HIT UPON THE KEY ISSUE.
KEY ISSUES THAT THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT STANDARDS FOR WHAT'S
FLUSHABLE ONE IS IN INDIA'S
INDUSTRY STANDARD AND THE OTHER
IS A STANDARD THAT WAS COME UP
WITH.
THE SANITATION -- PROVIDERS --
AND THERE WAS A MEDIA I WENT
THROUGH ALL OF THIS WITH THE
EXPERTS AND BELIEVE ME THIS IS A
VERY COMPLEX ISSUE.
AND THERE ARE A GENUINE
ARGUMENTS ABOUT HOW MANY OF THE
AND WHEN YOU'RE LISTENING TO THE
EXPERTS YOU REALLY DO HERE --
THAT TED YOU KNOW WHEN THEY DID
THAT AND IN NEW YORK IT WAS
RIGHT AFTER A BIG.
OUR WATER EVENT A STORM AND THAT
CHANGES THE RESULT AND YOU'RE
NOW YOU CAN LISTEN FOR EVER.
SO BUT THERE ARE JUST BASICALLY
AN INTERNATIONAL STANDARD ALL
CALL IT AND IT INDUSTRY STANDARD.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHERE THE
CONTENTION IS.
AND I JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR TO THE MEMBERS WHO ARE
HERE -- DO WE HAVE MEMBER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
NOT SURE -- MADAM VICE CHAIR YOU
CAN GO IN FIRST.
THANK YOU OKAY [inaudible]
SO I I'D NEVER THOUGHT WE WOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT THIS TOPIC
APPEAR BUTTON THIS IS MY
FAVORITE BILL IT MAY BE A FIRST
BUT WERE ALIGNED ON THAT.
THIS IS MY ABSOLUTE FAVORITE
BILL OF THE DAY -- AND I DON'T
KNOW WHO ENDS UP WITH THE JOB OF
DOING THE FORENSIC ANALYSIS ON
THE CLOCK BUT THEY SHOULD GET
PAID A LOT OF MONEY TO DO THAT.
OKAY -- SO.
SO I'M LOOKING THROUGH YOUR BILL
HERE IN THE IN THE IN THE CHAIR
I YOU KNOW HE BRINGS A VERY
VALID POINT WHICH IS THERE ARE
SOME DISCREPANCIES IN
DISAGREEMENT ON WHAT STANDARDS
SHOULD BE MET.
BUT AS I'M LOOKING THROUGH YOUR
BILL AND I THANK YOU SEE.
YOU WANT.
NON FLUSHABLE WIPES TO BE
CLEARLY MARKED THAT THEY'RE NOT
FLUSHABLE.
AND THERE'S SOME DISORDER SAY DO
NOT FLY RIGHT AND THERE'S
DISCREPANCY ABOUT.
DOES IT SAY THEY ARE FLUSHABLE.
OKAY WHICH MAKES SENSE SEP IRA.
WHEN A SHOPPING TRIP TODAY?
VERY GOOD SO IT'S LIKE SHOW AND
TELL OKAY.
WE HAVE BASS WIPES THESE SAY DO
NOT FLUSH [inaudible]
THIS IS.
DAY LOGIC RAN AWAY.
CALMING MAKEUP REMOVER WIPES.
I MEAN KEEP THOSE BE SAY DO NOT
FLUSH.
WE HAVE.
CEDARVILLE GENTLE MAKE UP
REMOVING.
ONE DO NOT FLUSH.
HUGGIES DO NOT FLUSH.
WINDEX DO NOT FLUSH.
I MAKE UP REMOVER DO NOT FLUSH.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW THESE EXISTED.
ADULTS WASH CLOUDS DO NOT FLUSH
I FOUND EVERY PRODUCT I COULD
FIND THAT SOME SORT OF WHITE
BROTHERS FOR CLEANING YOUR FACE
CLEAN YOUR WINDOWS CLEANING THE
COUNTER.
I FORGOT TO CLARK'S WIPES BUT
THERE'S A DO NOT FLUSH -- TO
THEY ALSO YOU DO NOT QUESTION
THEY ALL HAD THE SYMBOL ON THERE
IN CASE YOU YOU KNOW WE DON'T
KNOW HOW TO READ YOU CAN
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT.
SYMBOL OF THE TOILET EVERYTHING
SAYS DO NOT FLY SO I'M NOT.
IS THERE SOMETHING OUT THERE
THAT SAYS THAT THAT'S A THAT'S A
WIPE THAT I DON'T KNOW ABOUT.
BECAUSE ALL THESE PRODUCTS I
COULD HAVE PURCHASED MORE I JUST
YOU KNOW TRYING.
TO KEEP MY LIMITS ON MY BUDGET.
YEAH I I MEAN FUND IS A WAYS TO
GO THERE AND YOU KNOW BUT IS
THERE SOMETHING ELSE OUT THERE
OTHER THAN THE TUG ABUSE BUT
THOSE ARE SUPPOSE THERE'S ARE
FLUSHABLE WIPES I'M TALKING
ABOUT THINGS THAT.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE FLUSH SO WE ARE
ASKING FOR THE INDUSTRY STANDARD
FOR DO NOT FLUSH LABELING TO BE --
REQUIRED -- STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT SO THAT INDUSTRY
STANDARD -- CALLS.
FOR THAT SPECIFIC DO NOT FLUSH
MOUNTED MONIKER TO BE INCLUDED
ON EACH PACKAGE ON THE FRONT OF
THE PACKAGE IN A CLEAR AND
CONSPICUOUS -- MANNER A ARE ALL
CLEAR AND CONSPICUOUS AND SO THE
THIS THOSE WIPES THAT YOU HAVE
MAY BE YEAH -- ABIDING BY THE
INDUSTRY STANDARD BUT IT IS A
VOLUNTARY STANDARDS SO THERE ARE
CERTAINLY WIPES ON THE MARKET
THAT HAVE NO INFORMATION ABOUT
THEM WHATSOEVER ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATE THAT WHAT IT IS LIKE
A LITTLE.
WIPES THAT MAYBE ARE IMPORTED
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES WIPES THAT --
DID JUST ARE AVAILABLE FOR
CONSUMERS FOR PURPOSES THAT THAT
THEY MAY NOT SEE FIT TO INCLUDE
INFORMATION ABOUT DISPOSAL ON
BUT THEY'RE CERTAINLY AVAILABLE.
DO YOU KNOW THE BRAIN THE BRAND
NAME I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
SOMETHING AND OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK A JUDGE DO
I THINK WE'VE ESTABLISHED
[inaudible]
THAT FACT.
SO I THINK YOU CAN GO ON TO YOUR
NEXT QUESTION.
THERE'S A FACT ESTABLISHED SHE
DOESN'T NOW OKAY -- I MEAN I'M
NOT TRYING TO BADGER HER I'M
JUST I'M GENERALLY ASKING A
QUESTION BUT WE WILL ME WELL SHE
SAID SHE DOESN'T KNOW.
OKAY YOU CAN GO ON OKAY SO.
IF I COULD JUST -- ARTICULATE A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER I DON'T THINK
THERE'S A DISAGREEMENT.
BETWEEN THE OPPOSITION OURSELVES
THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM OUT
THERE WITH -- THINGS NOT BEING
MARKED PROPERLY THE QUESTION OF
WHERE WE DISAGREE IS.
WHERE THE LINE GETS DRAWN?
SO I THINK THERE'S GENERAL
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THESE
PRODUCTS ARE -- OUT THERE
THEY'RE AVAILABLE PEOPLE ARE
USING THEM AND THEY'RE DISPOSING
THEM IN WAYS THAT THEY SHOULDN'T
BE DISPOSED OF OKAY END THANK
YOU FOR ADDING TO THAT -- I JUST
I KNOW THAT.
WE HAVE THESE CLOGS I THINK
THERE'S A PERCEPTION THAT --
IT'S ALL DUE TO THESE FLUSHABLE
WIPES AND I DON'T I JUST DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU CAN PROVE THAT EVEN
GET.
GIVEN A FORENSIC ANALYSIS --
THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
JUST FLUSH HIM EVEN THOUGH THEY
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW IT SAYS RIGHT
ON THERE DO NOT FLUSH WHICH I
CAN'T IMAGINE DOING BUT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE DO IT.
SO I'M NOT EVEN I JUST I'M NOT
CERTAIN.
HOW THIS BILL WOULD STOP THAT
BEHAVIOR -- BUT I'M I'M OPEN TO
HEARING -- YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
WHAT YOU'RE SOLUTIONS TO THIS
SUMMER THE BILL IS INTENDED TO
HAVE UNIFORM -- CAUGHT LET A
UNIFORM LABELING REQUIREMENT.
AND THEN YOU'RE RIGHT IT IS
GOING TO TAKE EFFORT TO GET
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
FLUSHING THESE PRODUCTS -- IS IS
A PROBLEM.
BUT UNTIL YOU HAVE UNIFORMITY IN
YOUR STANDARD YOU REALLY -- EAT
YOU CAN'T CREDIBLY TELL THE
PUBLIC THAT SOMETHING CAN'T BE
FLUSHED IF IT'S NOT MARKED IN A
WAY THAT THEY THAT THAT IS
UNDERSTANDABLE.
IS THIS I'M I'M JUST WONDERING
IF THIS IS IT WOULDN'T BE A A
BETTER -- SORT OF GRADUAL
APPROACH TO FIRST.
TRIED TO ESTABLISH WHAT STANDARD
IS GOING TO BE USED AND THEN
ONCE WE GET PAST THAT POINT THEN
TALK ABOUT.
THE LABELING WELL I THINK THIS
IS A GRADUAL APPROACH I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU START WITH ANYTHING
BECAUSE OF MORE GRADUAL THANJUST LABELING THINGS --
APPROPRIATE WILL THAT WE DON'T
HAVE AS I THINK IT WAS
REPEATEDLY STATED -- OF BY THE
OPPOSITION THAT -- TO THAT THIS
BILL WAS A BAN ON SOMETHING -- I
THINK YOU ALL KNOW -- I'VE DONE
TAX BILLS I'VE DONE A LOT OF
I'VE I'VE BAND A LOT OF THINGS
THAT -- AT ONE POINT I HAD A
NICKNAME SENATE ALONE.
NO IT'S BEEN A BLOOM -- SO I
KNOW WHAT ABANDONED THIS IS NOT
A BAND THIS IS A LABELING BILL
THAT -- ALLOWS PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND CONSUMERS TO
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IS POSSIBLE AND WHAT IS NOT?
THAT SIMPLE.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW MY NAME THIS IS THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT WE CAN ALL
UNDERSTAND SO THERE'S LOTS OF
QUESTIONS [inaudible] TWO
DOLLARS.
SO -- SOME MEMORABLE MY I'M
KINDA IN THE SAME MAYBE.
CONFUSION OF MY COLLEAGUE --
MISS MELINDA SO WHEN I DO FEAR
CONFUSION.
WELL SO CAN YOU CAN YOU CAN CAN
YOU DETERMINE WHEN YOU CLEAN A
CLOG OUT WHETHER IT WAS A NON
FLUSHABLE WIFE OR A FLUSHABLE
WHITE WHEN YOU WHEN YOU.
YEAH NOT THE FOG OKAY YES THERE
ARE -- DESPITE WHAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING THERE ARE -- FIELD
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN CONDUCTED
THAT -- DEMONSTRATE.
SEVERAL IFFERENT TYPES OF
FLUSHABLE LABELED WIPES GOING
THROUGH THE SYSTEM AND SHOWING
UP.
AT THE TREATMENT PLANT FULLY
INTACT SOME TO DISPERSE -- A
LITTLE BIT OTHERS JUST BURST
COMPLETELY -- BUT WE CERTAINLY
DO HAVE THE EVIDENCE TO SHOW
THAT NOT ALL OF THEM MEET THOSE
HI PERFORMANCE AND METRICS AND
THEY THEY THERE IS A VERY LARGE
VERY AUNTS AND HOW THEY PERFORM --
AND THEN ANECDOTALLY YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REASON TO BE
MAKING UP THIS PROBLEM.
OUR FOLKS IN.
THE SEWER -- SYSTEM --
OPERATIONS DEPARTMENTS -- THE
REPORT SEEING THESE FLUSHABLE
PRODUCTS COMING THROUGH AND
BEING PART OF THE RAGS ALL THE
TIME I GOTAN EMAIL FROM.
ON THE LONG BEACH TREATMENT
PLANT JUST LAST WEEK SH
DEMONSTRATING A RAG A CONDO AND
EXPLICITLY STATING BY THE WAY A
LOT OF THE RAGS THAT YOU SEE IN.
THIS MASS OF PRODUCTS ARE THE
FLUSHABLE TYPES THERE'S NO
REASON TO MAKE THAT UP -- AND WE
KNOW FROM OUR EXPERIENCE -- THAT
THAT IT THAT IT IS A PROBLEM AND
THAT -- YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE'S
NO STATUTORY REQUIREMENT --
THERE'S NOTHING HOLDING THESE
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR HOW
THEIR LABELING THESE PRODUCTS
AND YOU CAN LABEL A GOLF BALL AS
FLUSHABLE AT THE MOMENT AND
THERE'S NOTHING SAYING YOU CAN'T
DO THAT -- SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS THERE JUST NEEDS TO BE A
CLEAR CONSISTENT LABELLING
REQUIREMENTS -- THAT.
THE EXPRESSLY STATE THAT --
FLUSHABLE PRODUCT -- CAN BE
CALLED FLUSHABLE IF IT ACTUALLY
DISBURSES IN THE SYSTEM
APPROPRIATELY AND DOESN'T CAUSE
DAMAGE.
OKAY MY SECOND FOLLOW UP TO THAT
IS SO.
I THINK WE HAVE A REALLY THE
WELL TWO THINGS I THINK IS THE
ISSUE IS THE NUMBER.
ONE THE THE PUBLIC IS NOT
EDUCATED ON I'M ASSUMING A
MAJORITY OF FLASH NON FLUSHABLE
GET FLASHED NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO MAYBE.
SOME OF THE STOP THIS DETERMINE
POSSIBLE ISN'T REALLY SUITABLE
FOR OUR SYSTEM MAYBE AND I KNOW
THAT TOM.
MY EXPERIENCE IN WORKING WITH CS
DIS OVER THE YEARS.
AND NOW THAT WE'VE CHANGED OUR
POLICIES TO LOW FLOW SYSTEMS WE
DON'T HAVE THE VOLUME OF WATER
TO ACTUALLY.
MOVE.
THE PRODUCTS THROUGH THE SYSTEMS
THAT WERE DESIGNED FOR A HIGHER
FLOW OF WATER SO I THINK THAT
MAYBE HASN'T BEEN TOUCHED ON
HERE WHICH IS NOT A PROBLEM OF
THE FLUSHABLE SO.
IT'S A PROBLEM OF WE JUST ARE
REDUCING OUR AMOUNT OF WATER AND
BE ABLE TO TAKE THE AFFLUENT.
AND DEBRIS AND MOVE IT THROUGH
THE SYSTEM.THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WIDE LIKE
TO MAYBE TOUCH ON THE OTHER
THING.
THE OTHER THING I THINK THIS.
CONCERNING TO ME IN THE BILL IS
THAT.
REQUIRES VIOLATES RECALL THEIR
PRODUCT WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF
VIOLATION NOTICE OF CALLIE PA
AFTER WHICH THEY ARE SUBJECT TO
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES UP TO
FIVE HUNDRED A DAY AND ALSO
SUBJECT VIOLATORS TO LEGAL
ACTIONS AND CIVIL PENALTY.
PENALTIES UP TO TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
VIOLATION BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THAT'S LOOK AT THE OTHER
DAY I WANT TO I WANT TO GET
THESE OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
I WANT POSSIBLES TO WORK I WANT.
TO OUR COMMUNITY TO UNDERSTAND
IT BUT I THINK THIS.
IS -- PRETTY AGGRESSIVE AND I
THINK WE HAVE MAINLY A
COMMUNICATION PROBLEM OR A
PUBLIC NOT UNDERSTANDING WHAT.
WHAT THE WHAT THEY SHOULD AND
SHOULDN'T FLY SO?
IT'S REALLY MAKING IT ME HARD TO
GET TO A POINT WHERE I CAN.
BUY ONE SOLVE THE PROBLEM BUT I
THINK THIS IS MAYBE.
NOT QUITE THE RIGHT APPROACH
WELL I LET ME SEE IF I CAN HELP
A AND M'S GOVERNMENT WANT TO ADD
TO THIS BUT THE BILL IS BEING
AMENDED -- THE PENALTY LANGUAGE
IS THE IS THE SUBJECT OF THE
AMENDMENTS HANDED OUT THAT I DID
GET A CHANCE TO READ.
OKAY THANK YOU THE AG WILL STILL
HAVE ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY BUT A
LOT OF THE OTHER LANGUAGES
REMOVED.
ALL RIGHT -- NEXT IS MISS GARCIA
AND THEN MISTER -- MATHIS COULD
YOU ADDRESS THAT FLOW ISSUE THAT
YEAH I'M SORRY.
FIRST ACTUALLY -- THE LOW FLOWS
ISSUE IS -- REALLY INTERESTING
LIKE YOU MENTIONED CALIFORNIA
HAS -- A LOT OF CONSERVATION AND
SO INDEED THE FLOWS ARE MUCH
LOWER HERE -- IN RELATION TO
WHAT THEY MAY BE IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY WHERE SOME OF
THESE STUDIES.
HAVE BEEN DONE -- THAT ACTUALLY
IS FAVORABLE TO THE STANDARD
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING BECAUSE THE
STANDARD THAT WE'RE PROPOSING --
ONE OF THE METHODOLOGIES
REQUIRES -- SORT OF A GENTLER
TURBULENCE IF YOU WILL WHEN
YOU'RE TESTING THE PRODUCT --
AND SO THAT WOULD BE MORE
REFLECTIVE OF THE SEWER SYSTEM
WITH LOWER FLOWS AND THEN WHEN
YOU HAVE LOWER FLOWS CLEARLY
THERE'S MORE DEBRIS IT TAKES
LONGER FOR IT TO MOVE IN THERE
MORE OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR THE WHITES TO GET CAUGHT AND
IN THE PROCESS.
SO THAT'S MY POINT IS THAT WE'VE
BECAUSE THIS BY LOW FLOWS NOT SO
NECESSARY THE MANUFACTURE SO I
THINK WE WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS TO A MAYBE TRY.
TO COMPLY WITH SOMETHING THAT
THEY DIDN'T REALLY BECAUSE IT'S
BECAUSE OF THERE'S A LOW FLOW
THAT'S BECAUSE THE ISSUE AND
WHEN YOU HAVE LOW FLOW AT LEAST.
AGAIN I ACTUALLY WORKED WITH
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICTS YOU
ARE FACED WITH THIS.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH FLOW SO IT
PILES UP AND THEN WHEN YOU DO
GET FLOW IT'S SLUGS THE SYSTEM
AND YOU GET THESE CLOCKS.
THAT'S NOT THE MANUFACTURER'S
FAULT.
MAYBE IT'S A CONSEQUENCES OF THE
ENVIRONMENT WE'RE IN BUT I THINK
WE SHOULD NOT PENALIZE THE
MANUFACTURES BECAUSE WE'VE.
CONCERT AND DONE A GREAT JOB OF
CONSERVING WATER WHICH IS THE
MAIN PRODUCT THAT MOVED THE
AFFLUENT OUT TO THESE PROCESSING
PLANTS [inaudible]
OKAY.
GARCIA YEAH MISTER BLOOM MEET
YOU HAVE THE MISFORTUNE THAT
I'VE BEEN IN THIS ROOM ALL DAY.
HA HA THIS IS NOT MY FOR IT BILL
BUT I WILL BE VOTING FOR THE FOR
THE BILL TO DAVID I'M A LITTLE
GRUMPY SO I APOLOGIZE IF I'M NOT
GONNA.
YES MY QUESTION FROM THE BEST
WAY POSSIBLE RIGHT NOW.
BUT WE HAD THERE'S THERE'S
DIFFERENT STANDARDS TO BE
ADOPTED IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE US AND AND IN EUROPE ALSO.
IN SO.
AND MR QUIRK STARTED OUT BY.
WAY NOT WHY WE'RE HERE AND THE
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN WHERE YOU'RE
AT AND THE APPOINTED TAR.
CAN I HAVE A MOMENT TO LET THE
OPPOSITION ANSWER ME WHY THEY
THINK THAT MAYBE THE SANDERS
BEING -- ADOPTED IN EUROPE.
AS A BETTER WAY TO GO AND THEN
YOU CAN RESPOND TO THAT AND IF
YOU EVER DECIDE THAT I'M SORRY
IT'S IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY AND SO
ON I'M ALSO HAVING A HARD TIME
LISTENING TO EVERYTHING.
A GOOD SO I APOLOGIZE AHEAD OF
TIME IF YOU ALREADY ANSWERED
THIS QUESTION.
SO I AM AGAIN THANK YOU -- I'M
JIM LOFTIS WHEN I WAS THE FORMER
TECHNICAL DIRECTOR OF AND I WAS
SAID INTO FOR THREE AND A HALF
YEARS.
AND DID A LOT OF WORK ON THE
FOURTH EDITION OF THE GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT.
THE SINGLE BIGGEST ISSUE I THINK
WITH THE I. W. S. OF G. STANDARD
WHICH IS THE INTERNATIONAL
INTERNATIONAL WASTE WATER.
AND ASSEMBLYMAN BLOOM MENTION
THAT THIS IS IN A BAND EXCEPT
THAT THAT -- STANDARD
ESSENTIALLY -- FAILS EVERY --
NONWOVEN DISPERSIBLE FLUSHABLE
WIPES THAT'S ON THE MARKET IN
NORTH AMERICA TODAY -- AND SO
THE OTHER STANDARD WHICH IS THE
IN THE IT ON A STANDARD WHICH
WAS DEVELOPED -- NOT ONLY BY
INDUSTRY BUT THIS IS THE FOURTH
ADDITION AND WE SPENT A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF TIME
TALKING.
TO THOSE IN THE WATER SERVICES
INDUSTRY OVER THOSE YEARS THIS
WORK HAS GONE BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO AND SO WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THAT STANDARD WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE IN THE IT ON A
STANDARD -- THE WIPES THAT
PASSED THAT STANDARD HAVE NEVER
BEEN SHOWN TO CAUSE THESE ISSUES.
RIGHT WE WE'VE NOT WE'VE ASKED
FOR DATA WE'VE ASKED FOR
INFORMATION THAT WOULD SAY YES
THAT FLUSH WIPE THAT PASSED
EITHER GT THREE OR NOW GT.
FOUR IT IS THE CAUSE OF THAT
ISSUE AND AND WE'VE NOT SEEN
THOSE.
THE INDIVIDUALS IN EUROPE THE
THERE'S INTO ANY DONNY DON IS
THE EUROPEAN NONWOVENS
ASSOCIATION WE'VE WORKING
JOINTLY WITH THIS -- WE'VE
ENGAGED -- WASTE WATER
PROFESSIONALS IN BOTH THE
EUROPEAN UNION AS WELL AS IN IN
THE U. S. AND THE THE RESPONSE
FROM THE FOLKS IN EUROPE IS.
LOOK WEAK WE STANDARDS TO BE
GOOD ENOUGH TO SEPARATE OUT
THOSE NON FLUSHABLE MATERIALS
WHICH HAVE VERY VERY HIGH WHAT
STRENGTH LIKE THE BABY WIPES
WHICH WE NOW WE'VE WE DID SOME
TESTING WHERE WE TOOK BABY WIPES
WE CLOGGED IN EIGHTEEN HORSE
POWER PUMP.
WITH BABY WIPES WE KNOW THOSE
BECAUSE ISSUES IN THE SYSTEM.
AND THEN THERE'S THE LOW WHAT
STRENGTH WIPES WHICH ARE THE
FLUSHABLE WIPES.
THE FOLKS IN EUROPE THAT WE
SPOKE TO THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
THOSE AREN'T THE PROBLEMS.
THE PROBLEMS THAT EXIST OR THE
MATERIALS THAT ARE BEING FLASHED
THAT SHOULD NEVER BE IN YOUR
SYSTEMS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THAT'S THE ISSUE AND WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS EDUCATION
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
I TAUGHT A COURSE THAT IN THE
AND I BROUGHT THIS UP THIS WHOLE
PART I THINK YOU'VE ANSWERED THE
QUESTION.
OUR I I WILL ALSO SAY THAT --
THE SPONSORS WILL TELL YOU THAT
THEY HAVE FOUND.
WIPES THAT ARE FLOOD SUPPOSEDLY
FLAT WELL I'LL TELL YOU.
FLUSHABLE WIPES WIPED OUT MY
WHOLE DRAINAGE SYSTEM IN MY
HOUSE AND THAT'S YOUR NOW I
GATHER A GUARANTEE YOU THAT
ANYONE WHO.
WHO ENDS UP FIXING THESE
PROBLEMS WILL TELL YOU NEVER
FLEISCHER FLUSHABLE WHITE?
JUST SAY AND ET WOULD YOU.
SO THERE IS DISAGREEMENT
OBVIOUSLY THE PROPONENTS FEEL
THAT.
THEY DO HAVE GOOD EVIDENCE THAT
FLUSHABLE WIPES YOUR PROBLEM.
THE OPPONENTS DO NOT -- I'VE
LISTENED TO BOTH SIDES AND JUST
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THEY
ARE.
AND I WILL SAY THIS RIGHT THAT
TELLS ME NOT TO FLASH.
ANY SORT OF WEAPON ALSO TELLS ME
TO ABANDON MY SHERMAN.
PAPER PROCESSING FEE RECLINING
EVERYDAY ACCORDING TO HIM BUT
THE VERY SCARY STORIES.
ALL RIGHT MISTER MATHIS HAS A
QUESTION [inaudible]
SOLD.
MY COLLEAGUES MOSTLY YOU KNOW
I'M I'M A PARENT WITH THE CHILD
WITH DISABILITIES.
AND FLUSHABLE WIPES ARE KIND OF
A WAY OF LIFE IN THAT COMMUNITY --
THERE THERE'S NOTHING LIKE
HAVING TO CLEAN UP YOUR YOUNG
CHILD -- WHO DOESN'T HAVE
CONTROL OVER THEIR BATTLES?
ON AND YOU KNOW ALL THE THE
BACKS OF THIS BILL I MEAN IT'S
IT'S THIS IS A LABELING BILL.
ENFORCEABLE LIVES -- CLEARLY
MARKED FLUSHABLE THEY'RE SOLD AS
FLUSHABLE -- MOST.
THEY'RE THEY'RE USUALLY SEPARATE
FROM -- REGULAR WIPES IN IN
DIFFERENT COSMETIC WIPES LIKE
MISSILE AND IS IS IS BROUGHT IN --
BUT I'M JUST TRYING TO IMAGINE A
WORLD WHERE.
YOU KNOW ME AND MY WIFE HAVE TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR CHILD.
WHO DOESN'T HAVE CONTROL OVER
HIS BOWELS BECAUSE OF A SPINA
BIFIDA?
WHERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE A HUGE
MASSIVE PILE OF OF REGULAR WIPES?
THE COULD COLLECT WHILE WE'RE
HAVING TO DO WITH HIS NIGHTLY
ROUTINES -- IT AND HE'S LIKE.
FOR SO I'M TRYING TO THINK OF
WHAT THAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE
FOR ANY AND ADULTS.
WHO HAS SIMILAR PROBLEMS AND AND
THOSE THINGS?
IN OUR AND AND LOOKING AT THE
THE BACK AND FORTH IN THE SENATE
ALL OF THIS I MEAN THERE'S
CLEARLY WAYS WHERE ON THE
MANUFACTURINGSIDE.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S WAYS THE CAN
DO BETTER JOBS ON ON THE WAY
THINGS ARE MANUFACTURED.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I I THINK.
FALL IN THINGS OFF THE SHELF
CREE PENALTIES DOING THIS IT'S
IT'S DEFINITELY A A STICK VERSES
A CARROT -- WHICH I'M NOT IN
FAVOR OF SO I'M TRYING TO REALLY.
FIGURE OUT WHO IT WITH ALL THE
WORK THAT I DEAL IN.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
COMMUNITY.
HOW THIS IS GONNA AFFECT THEM --
BECAUSE I COULDN'T IMAGINE
SOMEBODY TRYING TO GO IN AND AND
GET WIVES WITH WITH A LITTLE BIT
OF TIME THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO
GET TO THE STORE.
NOT BE ABLE TO FIND THEM THEM
NOT BE ON THE SHELVES BECAUSE OF
THIS TYPE OF LEGISLATION.
SO THAT THAT'S JUST A CONCERN I
HAVE.
A MEASURE YOU'D EMAIL BEEN
INSURE US THERE'S NOT GONNA BE A
PROBLEM OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
BUT IT BUT AS A FATHER THAT
DEALS WITH THIS ON A DAY TO DAY.
I HAVE VERY VERY LARGE CONCERN
AND I DON'T THINK THAT POINT AND
BROUGHT UP OF HOW OFTEN THESE
PRODUCTS ARE USED. FOR FOLKS WHO
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANOTHER CHOICE --
LET ME.
I TRY TO ANSWER THAT BUT
CERTAINLY -- YOU POINT OUT A
SENSITIVE ISSUE -- BUT IT'S NOT
NEW ISSUE -- YOU KNOW -- OF
FOLKS WHO HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS
HAVE BEEN AROUND OF GOV FOR TIME
IMMEMORIAL -- ADULTS WHO HAVE
NEEDS BABIES WHO HAVE DIAPERS.
YOU KNOW THAT NEED TO BE
DISPOSED OF SOMEWHERE THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY A QUESTION OF WHERE
ARE WE GOING TO DISPOSE OF
THINGS AND FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
BEFORE THE THESE PRODUCTS WERE
WIDELY AVAILABLE WE WERE STILL --
USING PRODUCTS TO CLEAN THINGS
UP AND WE WERE DISPOSING OF THEM
BUT THEY WEREN'T GOING DOWN THE
TOILET OF A FOR THE MOST PART --
THEY WERE GOING ELSEWHERE.
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S REALLY THE
ADJUSTMENT THAT A YOU KNOW IN
SOME WAYS WILL -- WILL NEED TO
BE MADE BUT AGAIN THIS IS ABOUT
THE COMPOSITION OF PRODUCTS AND
THERE'S NO REASON WHY -- THE
FLEXIBILITY STANDARD CANNOT BE
MET FOR PRODUCTS THAT YOU'LL
NEED TO USE -- WITHOUT WERE
SIMPLY POINTING OUT HERE THAT.
WE ARE AND I THINK AGAIN THIS IS
A MATTER OF WHERE YOU PLACE THE
STANDARD AND THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE TWO SIDES HERE -- BETWEEN
THE ODDS OF YOU KNOW MY POINT OF
VIEW AND THE AND THE OPPOSITION
BUT THE QUESTION IS WHERE DO YOU
DRAW THE LINE NOT SHOULD
EVERYTHING GO IN THE TOILET AND
TO BE WASHED INTO THE SEWERS AND
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY IS
ADVOCATING THAT EVERYTHING GOES
INTHE TOILET.
I MEAN.
WE WE ALL KIND OF GREW UP WITH
THAT COMMON SENSE OF IT NOW
FASHIONING DOWN THE TOILET THAT
DOESN'T NEED TO GET FLUSHED DOWN
THE TOILET RIGHT AND MOST OF US
GREW UP WITH THAT AND MAYBE SOME
OF THAT GOES BACK IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND AND PARENTS
BEING.
PARENTS ACTUALLY TEACHING.
THEIR KIDS THESE THINGS.
YOU KNOW I I THINK MORE MAYBE.
A ENOUGH YOUR BILL SAID OKAY IF
IT'S GOING TO HAVE THE LABEL
THAT IT'S FLUSHABLE THAN IT MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS BUT THE THE NON
FLUSHABLE WIFE ON ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF IT IS IS.
THAT'S WHERE GETS.
A LOT MORE CONFUSING WITH IT SO
OKAY THANK YOU AT THAT
ESSENTIALLY IS WHAT THE BILL
DOES.
I'M I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE SUIT
SHE'S ME SANITATION AGENCIES.
ARE THEIR FLUSHABLE WIPES THAT
PASSED THE INTERNATIONAL
STANDARD.
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
SO -- REPORT RELEASED -- JUST
LAST WEEK I THINK IT WAS TESTED
MOST OF THE WIPES.
THERE WERE AVAILABLE -- ON THE
MARKET TODAY AGAINST THE
INTERNATIONAL STANDARD --
SEVERAL OF THEM DO PASS EASILY
AND IT'S TRUE THAT A LOT OF THE
WIPES ON THE MARKET IN NORTH
AMERICA.
DO NOT -- NECESSARILY PASSED THE
STANDARD -- BUT WE DO KNOW BASED
ON THAT REPORT THAT THEY CAN BE
ENGINEERED.
THERE ARE WIPES WIDELY AVAILABLE
ON THE MARKET ON THE SHELVES IN
JAPAN THAT DISPERSED IMMEDIATELY
WHEN YOU PUT THEM.
INTO THE TOILET AND AND THERE
ARE ALSO AVAILABLE ANDTURKEY
SPAIN AND THE UNITED KINGDOM SO
IT CAN BE DONE IT.
HASN'T BEEN DONE HERE IN THIS
COUNTRY -- FOR THE MOST PART WE
DO THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
PRODUCTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND
STILL CONTINUING TO BE
ENGINEERED BY SOME OF THE BIG
COMPANIES.
IN THE UNITED STATES THAT SHOULD
BE ABLE TO MEET THE STANDARD
OKAY SO BEFORE I LOSE MY QUORUM.
OUR WOULD YOU MIND CLOSING MR
BLOOM AND WILL TRYING TAKE A
VOTE WELL WE STILL HAVE PEOPLE
HERE I THINK WE COVERED THE
TOPIC -- I WOULD POINT OUT THAT
THE A SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IS
THE ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES -- THEY'VE IDENTIFIED A
REAL PROBLEM THAT THEY'RE TRYING
TO ADDRESS AND THE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
SO THAT THAT PROBLEM GETS
ADDRESSED THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- I'M RECOMMENDING AN
ONLINE.
HOW COULD WE HAVE A MOTION?
MR OUR MOVES MISS REBECCA.
OUR CAN [inaudible]
OF SECONDS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO
BLOOM THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO KALRA.
KALRA I'D BAUER-KAHAN HI
BAUER-KAHAN HI DOLLY.
DALY NO CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I HOLDEN [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS KNOW WHAT I TO CHANGE.
OKAY SO WILL HOLD ROLE.
OKAY -- SO.
THIS WAS.
SO WE NEED.
ONE ALL RIGHT I'D LIKE THE
MEMBERS NOW TO CALM BECAUSE WE
HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF BILLS THAT
ONLY HAVE FOUR VOTES.
AND WILL GO OVER SOME OF THEM
NOW.
BUT IF MISTER MURATSUCHI MISTER
HOLDEN -- I DON'T KNOW WHERE.
IF THEY COULD ALL OUT COME IN
THE NEXT.
WELL I'LL BE HERE AS LONG AS IT
TAKES BUT I MAY HAVE TO GO
EXCEPT THAT I MAY HAVE TO GO OUT
TO GO TO COMMITTEE MYSELF ABOUT.
SO PLEASE COME QUICKLY
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE CAN ADD ON OKAY.
ALL.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO CALL
THE ROLL.
OKAY SO WE'RE ON AYE IT WERE I'M
ADDING ON CALLING THE ROLL ON
ITEM NUMBER -- FIVE IT'S AB
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE HOLDEN THE VOTE
IS AT TWO THREE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
I KALRA.
IT IS AB SEVEN FIFTY FIVE HOLDEN
IT'S THE ZINC.
OKAY HI.
CALLER I'D.
BAUER-KAHAN HI BAUER-KAHAN I
WHAT A TO G..
HE'S STILL MISSING SINCE. FIVE
TO THREE THAT ONE IS OUT.
OUT THANK YOU WITH ALL THE
OTHERS.
YEAH OVER.
WE WANT TO CALL THE ONES THAT
HAVE.
THAT HAVEN'T GONE OUT YET FIRST
AND THEN WE'LL GET TO THE OTHERS
THANK YOU.
SO ADDING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN THIS IS AB.
NINE TWELVE WHAT A TO G..
THE VOTE IS AT FIVE ZERO KALRA.
KALRA I BAUER-KAHAN HI
BAUER-KAHAN I HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS HI HE SAID THAT BECAUSE
OF EIGHT THAT'S BECAUSE WE DON'T
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING IN
ORDER WE'RE GONNA GO.
TO ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN AND THAT'S AT FIVE ZERO
THIS IS AB FIFTEEN OH NINE
MULLIN BAUER-KAHAN HI
BAUER-KAHAN SO THAT'S EVERYONE'S
VOTED ON THAT WHEN.
AT SIX ZERO THAT -- ONE ON AB
FIFTEEN OH NINE EIGHT SIX ZERO
THREE ARE NOT VOTING ON THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE CHIU.
THE VOTE STANDS AT SEVEN ZERO
BAUER-KAHAN HI BAUER-KAHAN I
WHAT A TO G.
. THREE FOUR MINUTES.
MR HOLDEN WITHOUT CAUSING THE
OKAY.
CAN I BET.
ON EIGHTY SIX FORTY SEVEN OUR
EVERNHAM [inaudible]
YEAH. EIGHTY SIX FORTY SEVEN FOR
YEAH [inaudible]
I HAVEN'T.
OKAY I WANT TO BE A NICE
ALTHOUGH I HAD NEVER TO GET JUST
A BIT I HAVE YEAH I THIRD TIME
THAT I'VE.
WILL WE'RE JUST GOING TO CONFIRM
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY SIX
FORTY SEVEN KALRA -- BAUER CANS
VOTE HI IS IT HI SO THAT IS.
SEVEN ZERO YEAH I HAVE
I WILL WRITE NOTES AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT -- THE ALL RIGHT HERE
WE NEED TO GET OUR SO SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO BLOOM SPELL.
OUR IF WE GET THIS SOON AS WE
CAN.
DO THIS [inaudible]
FOR YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH.
I'M HAPPY [inaudible]
TO OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO WE'RE JUST WAITING.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A FREE THAT
MEMBERS I DON'T.
SO WE HAVE NOT YET ADJOURNED
WE'RE GOING TO WAIT UNTIL.
ODD.
UNTIL MURATSUCHI AND HOLDEN
RETURN WHICH WILL HOPEFULLY BE
IN THE NEXT TEN MINUTES.
I'M GONNA GO PRESENT A BILL IN
HIGHER ED.
UP MISS.
OUR MS -- WE'VE GOT SOMEONE HERE
ALRIGHT MR HOLDING THIS YEAR.
LET US YEAR -- THE BELLS ON
WHICH MISTER WE NEED A VOTE FOR
MR HOLDEN STARTING WITH MR BLOOM
SPELL [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
OKAY.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO BLOOM.
THE VOTE IS AT FOUR TWO THREE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'D HOLDEN
[inaudible]
HOLDEN I FIVE THREE THE BILLS
OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B. NINE
TWELVE THE VOTERS EIGHT ZERO
HOLDEN.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
NINE TWELVE MORE AT SWITCHING.
HOLDEN I THAT'S NINE ZERO THE
TWENTY SEVEN FIVE AND FOR THAT I
HAVE YOU CAN I WE WERE HERE FOR
THE INITIAL
[inaudible]
THANK
YEAH -- YEAH -- I TO ATTEND THE
SHE SAID THAT COULD BE DONE YES
NO.
LANCE WILL BRING.
AND WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR
MISSED MURATSUCHI WILL WAIT
UNTIL TEN OUT
-- SAID.
YES HERE YEAH WE WE JUST REALLY
VALUE YOUR OPINION.
I FEEL THE LOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER MERRETT CG YEAH
SIR THERE ARE THREE BILLS --
ITEM IT'S ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE HOLDEN.
THE VOTE IS AT FIVE TO THREE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I WHAT A
TO G..
MURATSUCHI I SO THAT BRINGS THE
VOTE FINAL VOTE.
TO SIXTY THREE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO
BLOOM.
THE VOTE IS THAT. FIVE THREE THE
CHAIRS VOTING I BUT I TO CHECK.
RED TO GI [inaudible] SIX THREE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE CHIU.
THE VOTE IS AT EIGHT ZERO
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible] NINE ZERO WHAT
I AM HI. ONE MORE ITEM
[inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY WE'RE DONE ALL EVERYONE'S
VOTED ON ALL THE BILLS WE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH IF YOU DON'T NEED.
THEY'RE BEING.
NO ONE TO OBJECT I'M.
A JOURNEY AND